to
Hello everybody welcome it's Friday
sorry we're so late you know
I'd like to blame everybody but myself
but unfortunately yeah let's see you try
we all have an alibi
the traffic was crazy okay it was there
must have been like 10 accidents on the
way and there was like someone naked
running on the road there was police
there's helicopters in over the freeway
the freeway got swatted I heard gunshots
I saw smoke I don't know what's going on
out there guys be safe out there today
uh but in reality happy Friday May 12th
we actually were stumped on a title but
we just came through with something
really good I think Ela starts and only
fans
yeah thank you shout out
to uh
okay so and then the other thing is Lena
is doing sound bites right now because
Zach is at a wedding
oh
you want to hit us with one Lena just
see
you know just feel it out
Applause okay we love that oh
cut off got abruptly but that's kind of
good Ela you want to stunt on us a
little bit today
sure
um today's look we went for 90s grunge
love that and we're referencing Gwyneth
Paltrow and Kate Moss okay there's a
specific picture of Kate Moss in a car
and we did that and then going to pouch
for a picture like getting out of the
doorway and we did the same photos
you're gooping today I guess you could
say okay
it's a 90s group okay she was cool in
90s yeah Shakespeare in Love Gwyneth
Paltrow yeah we love her
not a contemporary group is there a jade
egg in you or no
I always found goop to be such a gross
sounding word I don't like it like
that's the sound that like sorry it's
vulgar but I imagine that's the sound
your vagina makes when you take out the
Jade Aid Jade egg honestly I agree
you know
[Laughter]
today's episode is sponsored by uh
PayPal hunting who we love love them
supported also by our wonderful members
members get my phone number and and uh
addition to all the other great benefits
and perks actually one perk I will say
for members which is going up on Sunday
is that we recorded
yesterday our first ever crew reaction
to Zach's lore video
we recorded we recorded about 40 minutes
of that and that's going up for members
on Sunday and Gabe is looking like I
love the haircut Gabe reporting from my
parking lot
Friday baby
I'm ready for the Roxy Baby
oh [__] yeah
you're at the you're at the Roxy already
wait no no tomorrow's the Roxy Baby
performance right that's performance at
the Roxanne I'm gonna be there to show
up
[__] even though even though Zach did
not attend your birthday party you are
rising above and attending his musical
performance
it's all right I gotta be the man
show some
recipes
[__] baby [__] gotta come to his senses
on that what what's what the parking lot
are you gracing at the moment okay
I'm at a castle
golf bar
where's the golf park
oh I know
he's at the mini golf course oh yeah
cute oh mini golf wait I didn't know
there was a mini golf place in L.A yes
over uh yeah
like the valley because the only one I
knew of Castle Park okay
because the only one I know of do you
know this place in Ventura Golf and
stuff yeah I know that one too but yeah
no there's there's one in the valley is
this one fire like Golf and stuff yeah I
used to go there as teenager all the
time because big arcades
up there you know
that's E40 that uh knows about it
or foodie
answering your questions
Lina's back there mixing it up I love
what I'm hearing thank you thank you I'm
happy to be here the real Joker brain
Zach should be scared to have you in his
back if you're listening I didn't say
this I'm not proclaiming this
well he abdicated the title on I mean
when we talked take it oh we we talked
about it in the crew uh members episode
Zach basically abdicated what's up
Dakota he it's like when a king steps
aside and gives his power away oh he did
yeah dangerous yeah no I agree so Lena's
about to scoop that title right up and
oh thank you abdicate Zach out of a job
so Gabe are you crushing it today at uh
mini golf
something during the day and then
tonight we're gonna have
we're gonna have a mini party and some
tequila shots because it's Friday yeah
you guys are gonna have a mini party
after your mini golf
Aaron
to select few people eat it I like the
idea of a mini part like a tiny little
bar
it is little bottles that'd be nice you
know
I remember at golf and stuff in Ventura
where I grew up yeah this was one of the
hot spots and it's right right on the
101 freeway yeah there's one street
small uh Street City street that
separates it that's where they film
Karate Kid
I called myself didn't they a dark kid
like an old one when he is on his date
with Ali
oh okay
oh that's the episode of Cobra Kai
[Music]
you start talking Cobra Kai yeah so well
what it wasn't just me a lot of kids did
this we'd go there and you guys know
mini golf with the ramps and [__]
uh so people used to go there and tee
the [__] up and slam the balls off the
ramps off the little bumps straight onto
the [__] freeway dude oh my God
and that's the 101 that's one of the
major inter uh uh uh freeways in the
whole country oh yeah I've never heard
of anyone dying or anything from it but
I've seen I've seen it man it happens
all day every day well I'll tell you is
that the one that Gabe's talking about
the one in the valley yeah right next to
the 405. and you know
I do know
I do know kids are [__] dumb as hell
but
oh [__] yeah we were I'm surprised
though that uh nobody's ever like killed
someone on accident doing that I mean
golf ball in the side window we know
that they haven't have we actually
looked ask Chachi BT
s sorry I you would think that if like
someone died they'd have to they'd have
to like put up a
you know like one of those driving
ranges Nets
but uh mini golf huh
I noticed we're jamming in this music is
there
it's mini golf Vibes just because okay
cool can you drink at the mini golf game
can you drink there
I don't know if we could it's like a
kid's thing right that's what I was
curious do they serve beer there
I don't think so it's just soda Pizza
chips that's all good stuff chicken
wings chicken wings chicken wings
that's all good stuff [__] I do like
the idea of people getting trash there
though and then hitting golfs onto the
405 Club falls on the 405. yeah I gotta
go there
well I have fun game that sounds really
nice it sounds like you're gonna have a
nice Friday with the fam you with your
family yeah
pretty much oh they're already in the
golf cart I'm just staying behind I like
that yeah
if you had any other
um dates with the uh love interest we
heard about a few weeks ago or is that
kind of just fizzled out a bit not
recently yeah not recently she's busy
you know
mini golf's a good date
yeah that would be a perfect date I
think it's a good day because there's
like lots of banter yeah you get you
could you could even get behind her and
tear up like no this is how you hit it
you know what I'm saying perfect first
date yeah I think so many golf just for
fun beach beach well don't color that
though I'm not yeah just making sure all
right you crush them out there don't
take any enemies don't [__] give them
an inch you're out there to kill and to
win you understand mini golf they think
it's fun but it's not it's serious
[__] business [__] just win baby
just win win at all costs
don't lose win at all costs don't ever
lose losing Zone
all right don't ever be a beta
yo I gotta hit some balls onto the 405
for old time's sake
all right Gabe you have fun out there
okay
yeah but good one
[Music]
that's what I say
baby [__]
let me speak
talk about the allegations
the parking lot is so beautiful yes this
is why I'm watching
because I know it nobody's watching all
right Gabe you have a great day love you
buddy thank you have a good weekend
[__]
White Club Gabe everybody out there
[Music]
yeah he's doing the important things
that we all wish we could do
you know that's not the first time he's
inspired me like oh that sounds like
something that we should do it's like a
fun connoisseur huh he is he is fun yeah
true Gabe really I mean he has the best
there's something very beautiful about
like Gabe just like doing fun little
things
it's like he's it's like he's out there
living the best life for all of us
all of us wage slaves and it's something
that anybody could go and do it's not
like oh I'm out here on my private jet
no
mm-hmm
but uh yeah we should actually go do
that so okay fun
um today we have a inspiring game
we have a great show today which is
unusual for us you know we've come
together well actually speaking of that
the last episode was my all-time
favorite I think
so much so that okay so I always watch
while driving so I kind of like tune in
tune out Miss stuff watch certain bits
and I loved it so much so that I'm gonna
I started going back and re-watching
everything to make sure I haven't missed
anything because I need to watch every
single part of it um
well you're not alone in that a lot of
people said it was their favorite
episode of off the rails ever and you
know you have to be
it was super fun the time went by so
fast everyone had so much fun doing it
the crew swap it was like the
culmination of all these personalities
yeah you have to be in really deep but
if you know all the lore and all the
characters and everything
was awesome yeah super fun and some of
y'all nailed each other like in a way
that was so funny
you know that was great we have some
good uh let's see some highlights
actually
let me pull some of those up
um here's a post just saying with uh
echoing your sentiment Ila best
1300 points
you know Not only was it constantly
funny but truly embraced the name of off
the rails yeah rapid improv constant
chaos yeah
it was legendary
uh the top comment is sending love to
Dan I loved all of them went really hard
I was having a lot of fun yeah
you know oh my God one thing that killed
me was when you asked Alfredo for his
Boba oh yeah
[Laughter]
what do you think about this Hilo
yeah so like it's a compliment and also
like a massive insult
so they everyone said oh Ethan looks
Daddy thank you everyone look Ethan
looks so daddy in the new episode with
all the Angles and he's lost weight and
stuff so here's Ethan in ABC
has handsome Squidward can you go sit
there for a second you want to see it
fair if you did that everyone saw that
[Laughter]
he's moseying really yeah
well there was I couldn't take the
direct package I wanted there's bumps I
got you okay so apparently this is my
this is your good this is my sexy
lighting which I don't think so you it
really highlights my so no I don't you
know what I think it's just the side
angle
that's how we used to record our
reaction videos I I liked that side too
Camry can I say some cad's been calling
it my gobbler and I have to say it's a
little offensive um
it is funny but I'm like damn this guy's
saying I have a gobbler no I said your
face I said your Gobbler's going away
your Gobbler's gone no you didn't say
it's gone you said it's gone weirdo
no more gobbler
[__] you baby yeah but I still have it
you know look at that thing it's not a
gobbler anymore I need to I need to um
it's just a Gob ice it off ice away what
is it
yeah he's off the fat
okay so here's sexy lighting Ethan okay
and also let me say that I am feeling
skinny today
let's go today
I was looking at the uh at myself in the
mirror this morning shirtless and I felt
that my stomach looked smaller okay wow
okay okay girl
also we should so happy for you
yes yes yes yes
straight up weirdos on the internet
that again keemstar man there's some
straight up weirdos
have you looked in the mirror what what
whoa I'm just saying your [__] nose
comparing the shot okay but now here's
the second part it's not the lighting
it's an angle Ethan in his seat
disgusting Hideout [__] up looking
red eye crackhead Squidward
yeah so ride my dick okay well yeah well
this is how I usually look so at least I
have you know it's better it's an
improvement at least you know this is
doable
so um now he's comparing me to Hitler
nobody I didn't nobody brought that up
no well we brought that up it's
interesting that you keep bringing up
Kim actually we're going to talk about
keemstar today
we are a long time oh what a throwback
that's pretty good keemstar gossip in
the news a vantage topic yeah but
because he's not really he's basically
retired is a nice way to put what he is
I mean he just kind of crawled into a
hole
was forced into a hole like a [__]
rat on a boat
it's that bad
so he's promoting a boxing event oh okay
it's quite good so anyway
um here's more Ethan uses swap seats
with AV not only is the lighting and
angle really complement his fine ass
skinny King self his hands be looking
massive you proved it okay are these is
this edited or is that a candid shot in
my big hand because my hand looks kind
of [__] unfortunately it's edited
okay how do you know that are you lying
I don't know I'm just [__] with you
foreign
is very close to the camera the camera
is much closer it wouldn't do that I'm
just telling you
do you want to start doing the show in
an angle analysis yeah you can we can
switch to the angle we don't have to
whatever if you guys can do an angle
that's like some Force perspective on my
hand
let's go back to mirror hand recording
you like the old videos yeah you'll just
hold the camera and hold the whole time
okay and then I was dying at Dan as cam
Lego head I thought it was pretty good
thanks thanks bro uh Teletubbies Dan
today was the best thing
I didn't see that one
gobble mode Ethan spabbing forbidden
soundbite I don't know if you heard that
part no you won't acknowledge it yeah I
need to
I was just playing nutritious sound like
nothing I mean nothing bad I haven't
made it to that part five percent yeah
just five percent
Dan and Ian as Olivia
yeah you guys were killing oh I can't go
to the right it's just Dan it's
happening Olivia how does it feel to
know that you are
the way everybody sees you is that you
are just this like light of positivity
all the time right oh my God how does it
feel it's time for you to stay that is
you are so beautiful and so sweet and so
kind it's true it was all just like you
supporting people yeah no I love that
girl
I have learned that I need to and my
vocab maybe I should stop saying slay or
Yaz maybe I say that a little bit too
much well you should start you should
start being mean to people that'd be
good yeah I'm totally bad for that era I
would like to see Olivia [__] era
I'm ready
uh how a b was looking once everyone got
back to their station
yeah I haven't made it to this part yet
was it that bad was everybody roasting a
b yes oh okay but it was really funny I
didn't I don't know why it happened it
happens like that AB I don't think it's
I think it's a compliment was it that
much I mean I didn't think so I I was
only I mean I was roasting him when I
was being him but I was doing that with
everybody I was just like exaggerating
their personalities but when I was you
Ethan yeah you didn't I was born I was I
was bullying ABC I know it's my favorite
no I didn't I didn't think it was bad
the only thing that pissed me off is
when I went to Ethan's spot and I'm like
oh we've been doing this [__] for an
hour and now it's my turn and then I was
calling out the fake version myself
everybody's like whoa Amy's really upset
I'm like uh there's no [__] there's
no winning that's not fair
I wanted to really give Abby the
opportunity for me to be a b and for a b
to be me we can still do that today
good
maybe I think you should own it I think
it's a compliment
I feel like I I got out what I needed to
I think so YouTube you change your mind
just yeah I'll let you know
I wanted to title today's episode Abe
quit
because of all the comments but we've
we've done I think we did Dan quit we've
done Ethan is ending the show so many
times Amy must have quit three times in
the clickbait verse yeah my favorite
host of off the rails was of course uh
yeah I love
you how does it mean
I think we definitely got to do this
again when loves if loves cinnamon oh my
God I mean oh yeah love was cracking me
up in the episode though with all of his
that's gonna be an interesting Dynamic
When Love Is there any random person
okay is there any updates love that you
want to say or no not yet we had a
little bit of a false alarm that made me
so am I I thought I got it for a good
two days wait and then turns out that
was kind of like a false alarm so I'm
kind of a little bit okay okay hold on
I didn't know that it was a false alarm
so what happened well we talked about it
so they approved the application they
didn't approve the Visa which is
different
I get help from this and yeah you got
like confused and I was like [__] yeah I
was in the grocery store when I got the
message from the person who's helping me
and I literally started crying oh no I I
went out of the grocery store no no when
I thought I got it I was like driving
home [__] crying I was like bro I'm
going and then like over the two days I
kind of slowly realized it's still big
up it's still like okay yeah W let me
parse this out
yeah
they accepted your application
see I I so the Lord I'm coming
so obviously working with lawyers is
kind of scary because you ask one
question boom that's like 200 so I'm
coming I know
kind of like I don't
I'll just let them figure out I'll wait
I'll get the answer when I get it
dude are you up to date on your shots I
actually do think you need to be up to
date on your shots too immigrate would
you stop yeah yeah
you have to get certain shots and stuff
yeah I'm just up you remember we have
probably similar stuff in Sweden as you
guys have
I have no memory of anything
in life
you get what did you have to get I don't
remember like ednis or some [__] yeah
whatever wasn't updated things like that
yeah you know rabies
do humans get rabies shots
if they get ready I think so yeah no
before rabies like to prevent rabies
because I know my dogs have it I got it
you know I got it I'm pretty sure I got
a rabies shot after I was bit certain
people with yeah for rabies exposures uh
are recommended to receive the vaccine
to help prevent rabies if exposure
happens because if you get exposed then
you're really the treatment is insanely
[__] horrible what if you actually
get rabies you mean
if you've been Expo if they think that
you are actually been exposed to a rabid
animal um you have to get like a series
of like eight shots
immediately too like within before you
show symptoms otherwise you're dead oh
dude rabies
I don't know if you guys know this about
rabies it's like the deadliest and most
[__] up yeah no idea
scratch moment
once you get rabies there's no cure the
only time anyone survived rabies is when
they put them in like a induced coma
they're trying to like keep their body
temperature and activity low but usually
they get brain damage from that does it
happen a lot no no it doesn't okay good
but that's why it's so scary because if
you get rabies dude it is the worst
death man oh my God it's so disturbing
after you get scared from water it's
called Hydrophobia you get scared of
water yeah bro it's bad
but Visa I'm getting the response within
literally days so I'm like walking and
like super stressed right now okay so
you will oh
it's crazy okay I got approved to not go
to the Embassy for the interview
so we sent it in two weeks or one week
ago and they have a two-week response
time so there's um is there why did you
not want to go to the Embassy well we we
petitioned to for me not to have to go
for the interview and they said sure I
guess it's because I have I'm so Public
public person maybe something like that
I'm not entirely sure we had to go to
Jerusalem for my interview
I remember yeah and I was so scared and
um I had to bring all the files whatever
a million things but then it was it was
totally cool yeah it was like okay cool
but mine show me it is show me that okay
you're good
my understanding is that once you get
the interview
yeah that's pretty much a done deal
pretty much like good to go unless
you're like Al Qaeda or something I
believe it are you Al-Qaeda so the the
last no okay no definitely you know good
answer
no not Al Qaeda Embassy
[Applause]
you know when we've been doing like kind
of offensive jokes and [__] like that
I've I've been like
no
I just don't want to risk anything okay
but so the application was accepted yeah
but so what is that does that mean
anything other than like because like
I'm just what does that mean can you
Google it yeah someone Google it because
like
it's accepted or did they tentatively
accept your application pending a review
or does it just mean they have your
application yeah just means they have
your application if I if I can guess
based on my experience it doesn't mean
like you're approved but then what would
they why would they reject an
application
they wouldn't unless something's really
wrong
if it's just technically not filled out
correctly and I need you to resubmit it
that could be like missing stuff yeah
I don't know
huh
I wish I had the answers I don't know
I've just been like I get the answer
when I get it I'm not gonna okay all
right all right well there it is uh
love is gonna be out here swapping
hopefully
very soon huh
all right
you know
speaking of the title Ela starts and
only fans which is obviously a gag a
reference to
some weirdos that like are genuinely
trying to make that iron punch in the
air right now and uh sorry bro [__]
but uh we'll talk about that in detail
but I just re something made me think
yeah that I saw a picture of c-man's
[__]
yesterday
during a company meeting as a company
meeting yeah we were sitting around and
Zach was like I saw a picture of
Seaman's dick oh it's not big
because c-man kind of uh stopped the
show in his last call when he told us he
has like a like a an 11 to 11 inch hog
here's my thing I want to believe him so
I'm not ready I'm not ready yet to say
that I'm on your side but I saw the
picture I know so did I it's literally
below yeah it's below average reference
reference can be weird sometimes and it
was weird because I expected it could be
the angle you want to see the photo
sure yeah do we have it
Zach had it uh that's walking around
with that on his phone it was a video
too from one of his weird shoes did I
saw one of his videos it was so [__]
weird bro that's what that's where his
[__] was in too because he like quickly
like
gave behind the scenes and shows his
penis in that video dude it looked like
a snuff film
it was terrifying horrible but there's
like two like okay
this was one of his uh office he it was
a role play that they're in the office
or something I mean that's probably one
of the things he would have wanted to do
here
yeah he's not doing that yeah thank you
I'm rescinding my offer
that offers off the table man I got it
uh but
it was real weird and his dick looked
real weird the head was like too big for
the stem but I was I was looking at like
a five incher Max
Chad's asking is he a grower he was
chubbed to me that looked that looked
like
like three-fourths chubbed
he wasn't fully torqued but like pretty
much there
and there ain't no there's not that much
growing left to do at that point that
video was haunted man dude it was so
weird really it was so weird I want to
show it to you man that was like some
dark web scaryness so but now
and now I need to bring c-man back and I
need to confront him on this Dan
I need to ask her why he why he always
lying
I assumed that c-man was honest to a
fault
right we did we always said that about
it would never lie to us not true I have
the picture you know how people can see
themselves a certain way send the photo
in WhatsApp but nobody look at it I mean
we've also maybe
um we've all seen it I haven't maybe
he's not lying because that is what he
truly thinks
about himself so it's it's not a block
it's tiny wait
wait so it's normal I mean it's not tiny
but it's pretty stubby
there's nothing wrong with it it's just
I mean he said nine to nine to eleven
it's just not nine three how long would
you estimate that to be
I don't want to say something it's c-man
what are you going to fencing man yeah
no he's a person that's feeling yeah he
came on my show and told me he's got a
[__] flip okay first of all so I
haven't watched the video all right I
don't need that then why don't you look
at it before you come out here and say
oh I'm being mean to Sea man this man
came out here and lied to my face we
[__] started our Saga with Seaman
need I remind you by accusing him of
something and we ended up being wrong
and we had egg on our face bro I saw he
was completely Vindicated
you see his face in the video is it
possible that it's not it's no it's him
I watched the whole [__] videos
that it's not yet it's not full yeah
maybe it's possible no there's not much
growing left to do there dude
girls you don't know anything about dick
let's be real who knows more about dick
but couldn't it be like completely
um what's the word like flaccid that's
not a flaccid cop no like he's holding
it
I don't know guys not in a flaccid [__]
right but man no thank you okay
you're getting the Council on it you can
tell that the head has got there's blood
flowing through it okay yeah that's I
don't know
that's um man science yeah
so um
it did post by the way is titled always
nice to be barefoot at work and comfy
and naked
that is always nice and it takes place
in what looks like a kitchen and a
company and a small office
hmm
so I don't know what you know I feel
like that's a big deal I don't know what
is this whole I just want to say there's
nothing wrong with this
dude I'm not coming out here and
[__] on little dick dudes I I want
to make that clear c-man lied to my
[__] face this man's been coming on
my show and telling me stories and at
least I gotta ask him what's with the
little dick bro
and and what I'd like to do
if anyone is available to help me with
that research now
because this is from his Reddit account
so can we Source more angles so that I
can make a more informed
uh decision on on his penis size
does anyone want to volunteer for that
research yeah I got you I got you
thank you bro and that's why you're
coming to America
the Visas oh yeah the Visas reserved for
people who
you can't find they're in college
America yeah the talent is so rare
we had to bring him all the way from
over there nobody here could do it true
you see nobody's raised in their hands
just spitting facts
so I thought that was pretty funny
honestly I wish I could show you guys
the video just because it's so odd
it's so odd
oh brother man that is one weird that's
the weirdest porn video I've ever seen
in my life
and well when c-man told me he had like
a 11 inch hog I was like
it's time to get
oh
I didn't want to say it uh everybody
yeah it's I mean it's okay
I was I was saying just the grand scheme
of things that we're talking about here
but I'm happy with that sure sure okay
always always like that I don't want to
discourage you we support you garlic
yeah
and we support you just to go back and
edit what I said a bit
uh he's the one that was telling me
who's walking around the bath house and
people are like following him around
like asking him to come in little
baggies and stuff okay okay I'm just
saying this man I have a right to know
how big this man's dick is after all
we've been got it yeah because without
the context this conversation might seem
a little bizarre
good yeah of course the context makes it
very important not weird at all though
no I think you're absolutely right or
not I'm entitled to know everything
about him sure
so love when you find some um
supporting or or
conflicting evidence
yeah definitely
yeah nice it is a crazy long penis
wow there you go okay is this Lena or a
B who's going she's walking dogs I'm
having a tough time today I don't know
why I'm I think really rich with her I
can't find [__]
you out walking the dogs huh
she right she just walked in here said
and turned around oh my God I was
covering her because she was eating at
first you're doing good everyone's yeah
good it was a massive penis thank you he
does it man
you know spoiler alert this is Amy's
penis I mean what I mean he's got a
choke he's got a fat head but it's not
proportional so it looks weird that's
not what it showed is right
this is short and stout right yeah well
you call that a mushroom dick
yeah a soda can yeah like that'd be a
joke
mushroom dick
I just like its own distinct thing
I don't wanna
make this too much about like thick
perfect Supremacy kind of conversation
like there's nothing wrong with it no no
it's just if you're out here bragging
about yes
all my little dicks always stand rise
the [__] up I don't care about y'all
you know what I mean he's talking about
c-man
now I want to see his [__] you want to
see the men and see what the man's got
see the manhood
so okay that's pending some further uh
investigation but okay hey I want to
congratulate Ela a second uh Vlog is up
yay and edited
by Lena yay
[Applause]
or people dislike me weirdos
oh yeah there's all kinds of weirdos how
they feel like they have to announce
like oh I didn't realize I was still
subbed to this channel let me fix it
real quick
I know what it is it's the same people
who've been unsubbing yeah
go off queens and kings go on to your
next life it's just funny to me that you
have to say it's like
okay
got him yeah homies we're leaving
yeah uh but it's really nice uh Vlog I
thought it was fun thank you we'll shoot
you guys have yeah you got these cool
outfits cool uh Studio space
it's all happening
this rocks here thank you Lena's back on
the board
come ones and two yes I was uh
congratulating you guys on the new Vlog
oh yes it was so much fun it was like
seeing Eli if any of you haven't seen it
yet I totally recommend it
um you just you get to see Elon like a
totally different element and it was so
much fun you guys are a bunch of [__]
love why would you say that I'm trying
to express themselves and be like
confident and quit they're trying to be
Queen while you tear them down such a
hater
I'm not a hater I'm all love baby
[Music]
crushing it
slaying it
and uh making it all happen so thank you
we got this this document froze
okay here it is my favorite host my
cousin Tim that was pretty good
shout out
that face when the soundboard just hit
two
yeah I was I was doing when I was doing
the bow blacks sound effects I was
trying to act like I was possessed so
every time it cut back to me I try to
look a little crazier wait so that's not
an edited photo
no that's probably you think my ears are
that big that a little late the
[__] from Men In Black right
there I can't believe you look like that
at that end I didn't think it was
editing yeah that was so crazy you on
Zach's camera no I mean I already look
insane so people didn't need to make an
edit
there must be some filter on his normal
show people think what this is just
normal IB yeah
yeah
Justified
this is cool maybe this one's kind of
complimentary just chilling whatevs
yeah Alfredo oh
my God
he's such a cute like so cute he's like
the nice Kremlin
in when he doesn't switch to himself
so there was we had a lot of fun
we learned why Ian
doesn't speak a lot on the show too yeah
yeah
Ethan finally understands how difficult
it is to speak while you're switching
with all the lay in the audio and
everything I didn't know that you should
try it
[Music]
on the earphones and talking it's crazy
that's good because it's about it's like
a half second delay and so everything
you're saying you're hearing yourself
back right after and again I don't know
it's short circuits my brain and Ian's
actually pretty good at it like he he
speaks he doesn't speak a lot but when
he does he doesn't seem bothered by it
so is there a way to fix that yeah I had
lunch
no it's just our switcher automatic it
has to delay everything to keep it in
sync so because the video the audio
comes before the video and so the audio
gets pushed back a little bit so
everything matches but that means when
you're listening to yourself speak it
gets confusing do me a favor and put the
put the camera on you Ela just sit there
and try to say something okay right
there put on the headphones and try to
yeah it's crazy
and right after we do this by the way we
should do our ads or at okay okay you're
gonna kill it excited to see you do the
ad girl yes
yes
Ela is stepping into the live switching
position she's putting on the headphones
okay so now just go ahead all right tell
me what what's your plans this weekend
[Music]
to survive yeah this is so weird
yeah very weird keep going just talk
I love
yo I don't know about you but it made me
start talking really slow yes it's like
when you call a zoom call oh this is
terrible
and and somebody has like the speaker
situation
not figured out okay can you hear
yourself twice yeah right thank you all
right
Hi Ian Slater one sub it was making me
feel all kinds of silly and goofy back
there
you did you were getting real silly
you're getting real silly with it oh my
God wait can we actually
so we went over a lot of great stuff
that I actually want to spend more time
on can we bring back the good doctor
segment because I actually want to watch
over all that together
heck our time on it
you know this will be the third episode
that we watch those clips it no yeah
because you did it on Tuesday although
that episode doesn't exist anymore so
it's kind of like history whatever it
goes down on Tuesday yeah all right well
as we do that let's say thank our
wonderful sponsor PayPal honey who we
love love love love today's episode
I guess I am usually okay A little
romantic
maybe not this for honey
or or maybe so I'm feeling it why not
[Music]
hey baby take some of that honey and
probably not a good lubricant yeah too
viscous
[Music]
are there two songs playing
no or this or though
but yeah again let's uh that's romantic
let's not do yeah not the romance music
during the ad read Because Ethan will
not be able to help him so okay there we
go
thank you to Honey today's episode is
sponsored by Honey the easy way to save
When shopping on your iPhone
or your computer Eli you are the honey
Queen since you're here I mean you how
much have you saved with honey Lots and
lots right it always works I mean well I
shouldn't say that not always but
whenever it does it's such a nice
surprise it's really fun how do you feel
when you find a deal I feel like I just
was so productive whenever that happens
it's like when you find 20 bill either
like on the ground or in a in the wash
in the dryer or something you're like
holy [__] you ever find a 20 a fiver
when you're a kid right like oh my God I
found a 20 at the amusement park once
that's when I was like 13. that's the
best thing ever life doesn't get better
it pretty I peaked I found a 100 Shaker
which is kind of like uh 25 bucks 25
bucks 30 bucks it made like I still
remember until this day
there was a pair of shoes I really
wanted and I bought the shoes I wanted
and it's like the greatest the greatest
thing ever you know what I should do
because I know how good that feels I
feel like I should probably just start
leaving twenty dollar bills on the
ground
nothing there's no better way to improve
someone's day right fully grown or a
child yeah
like you know a [__] giving a charity
right
let's put a little twenty dollar bills
everywhere that'll fix everything
hide it in random couches go to Kaiser
go to the health in the hospital yeah I
just got this half a million dollar bill
but I just found 20 bucks I'm feeling
good
yeah but uh today's episode is sponsored
by hunting you can feel that with honey
it manually searches for coupon codes
as a you check out at your favorite
online stores
it's a plug-in you install it in
basically two easy clicks it's free to
use
and as you're shopping and I'm talking
about all kinds of stuff I'm talking
about gadgets
clothing
you know food Furniture literally all
across the internet
uh as you're searching as you're
checking out a drop down comes down
and it says we found coupons do you want
us to apply them yes
automatically applies the one that's
going to save you the most money that it
can find
and that's it
you don't have to worry about finding
codes or you don't have to worry if
you're getting the best deal possible it
really is
the best now I would not be on the
internet without honey I wouldn't do it
it's just not it's just stupid
uh
honey doesn't just work on desktops now
it actually works on your iPhone too
just activate it on Safari on your phone
and save on the go that's exciting if
you don't already have honey you could
be straight up missing out and by
getting it you'll be doing yourself a
solid and supporting our show thank you
guys get PayPal honey for free at
joinhoney.com after dark that's
joinhoney.com after dark thank you so
much to Honey thank you please consider
supporting our sponsor thank you to them
love that
um
love were we able to Source any other
angles of c-man's deck so I've watched
every single video he posted since four
years back nothing no dick oh man really
that's the only one that's up that's
interesting
that's public at least there might be
some people stuff because he has a
subscription I'm cool with you doing a
paywall I'm totally fine with that you
have you know where to buy it I mean
yeah you can pay for it we're not
redistributing it I just want to see the
man's dick right bro I'll look into it
you have the company card no no I don't
and you got to do it
I'm not gonna do that
well I can reimburse you love it
say no more I'll reimburse you
actually I'm curious what the cost is
too if you can if walk me through it if
you're doing it yeah I'll look into it
I'm sure my accountant will be very
happy with this purchase
I wonder if they'll even ask they're
like only fans up brother oh wait it's
not no it's barefoot brother driving oh
yeah oh yeah
uh here's a b without a filter kind of
interesting
it makes so much sense yeah
yeah I was always confused by that um
uh let's see what else I've ever wanted
to kill somebody
sorry baby
Lena's afraid to commit to a zombie so
she hit the Applause and she's afraid
she's interrupting you so she's stopping
at halfway through it
you haven't done a single thing wrong
thank you also we're calling out a
notice to all fooper Troopers we are
sourcing
clips for our next lore video which is
about our faithful
young salaried employee Ian
we have a lot already but I think it's
important to speak to the community
there's lots of lore Masters there yeah
not to miss anything right might I
suggest to everybody so I've already
compiled sort of the script for it and
the obvious stuff that you're going to
think of is love of Kanye the
Powerpoints a-i-e-n
et cetera The Bachelor
Etc we got those we're good on those
what I want from you is your favorite
like deep cut Ian moment like uh where
he cut in and said something hilarious
or you know some obscure sketch that you
know we might have forgotten well like
you know what I mean there's lots of
iconic moments that just it's been so
long we've been doing this goddamn show
so many episodes
but anyway post on the subreddit and tag
it yeah there's a lawyer on the
subreddit when you create a post to
Market as a lore submission
so go ahead and do that so we can find
it easily so there it is we are working
on our next uh nice next one there oh
and love said uh and he's right time
stamps would be great
if it's on YouTube
link it with to the exact moment where
it is
thank you thank you thank you so much
the thumbs up the only fans thing just
because I guess we might as well address
it yeah so illustrating only fans guys
get to checkbooks out baby right time to
get those milkers out
I can't jerk off to this I've talked
about it on well yeah so I can't
remember that would be wrong oh they did
once I I think I talked about it on
Tuesday's member live
and then they removed it because on
Wednesday I was like these [__]
[__] yeah and I clicked but they
they had removed it
because I don't know if you saw my
messages with them no
but I was like yo y'all have to remove
this like that's not even funny like
what's wrong with you
and then they go we need Ela to send us
a photo of herself holding her
government-issued ID and a paper with
the date on it I was like are you
[__] out of your mind
ask the person who made the account
right to do that before you let them
impersonate someone and like again
there's nothing wrong with being on only
fans but it's something that is so
personal and something that is so uh and
is so good it's a heavy it's a heavy
duty uh commitment and so to put that
out there for somebody without verifying
the identity is crazy yeah and then
they're like show me a picture of your
butthole with a government ID and your
Social Security number your birth
certificate and send us one of your hair
that we can forensically analysis it
crazy dude that's crazy I think it's a
joke so they have to obviously do some
degree of verification even if people
when you initially sign up because they
they would have to not
at least know that people are of age so
I don't know dude because clearly that
person doesn't have any legitimate yeah
yeah it was just maybe the random troll
okay they photoshop the a fake ID or
something try to make an account let's
see let's make an account for a JLo
16 is the age of consent let's make an
account for not Jayla let's make up make
one for my female Alias uh
uh uh what was her name Ethel was it
Ethel right Ethel yeah
Ethel Klein
sign up to wait so this is just to sign
up to like have an account so you can
sub to people how do you make one
okay I'll try and figure yeah yeah let's
make an account for Ethel Klein I'm
about to show you guys my Cousy or
whatever
am I busy I don't know
I don't know what the terminology is
this is
Hassan's the expert with the OC stuff I
don't touch the OC stuff
I don't touch the stuff this whole uh
thing is so funny to me how
I'm sure it's the same people who went
from calling me ugly
to now they have like their new lines
some of them are like
oh uh go take care of your kids like now
they're assuming I'm doing too much like
so I don't have time to be a parent oh
because you're posting on Instagram now
yeah take care of your kids so I went
from being ugly to not a good parent or
excuse me women are not supposed to be
doing anything but taking care of their
kids the funny thing is that I saw that
comment last time on my Friday photos
and it's like I literally do that in 10
minutes before the show like
this is my work hours duh like I'm yeah
I'm a working parent everybody is
there's no [__] single household
there's no single parent household
working parent households anymore
like also who said a mom can't stand in
front of a camera
that's right it's just insane let's go
and then the other the other talking
point is that oh she's starting an only
fence and obviously the divorce
the divorce and all kind of times it's
just awesome
yeah
yeah these guys build these whole
fantasy worlds it's like she's
exercising okay now from that let's
extrapolate this whole uh fantasy world
where we're getting divorced ela's doing
only fans
she's [__] everybody and I'm not
taking care of the kids in foster care
yeah
just because you started working out
they built this whole universe which is
kind of true
it's not true at all keemstar stop
you're dating an 18 year old shut up
wait somebody 21. somebody just DM me
some very interesting information about
this they say for well so first of all
they say the fake Ela account was uh
wasn't verified it was just a user
account
uh it's the person that let us know
actually
um originally or one of the people that
reached out and let us know and then
they said when ID verified they get a
check mark and they said it's ID Plus
photo with ID plus 3D scan via phone for
model verification what I have been oh
what does that mean like you scan you
need to take it like a whole to take the
show that you're actually 3D scan via
phone for model verification
so basically
there's different kinds of accounts
there's different kinds of accounts a
viewer or a performer whatever it's
called well as a Layman no no no as a
Layman when I went to that page and I
saw people who are like just giant
[__] I don't know if they're I guess
some people believed it was real but
obviously the people that were posting
it knew it wasn't real that it looked
real
and uh
I thought I thought it was real or I
thought it was a real account I mean a
piece of [__] shut up keemstar
um
but yeah why are you so cute when you
talk [__] I mean someone posted on
Twitter that got like 10 000 likes that
were like he was starting only fans so
typical yeah beta Ethan letting his wife
do only fans I was like wow
weirdos
so okay so you're not starting at only
fans
is it totally off the table is there a
chance
no I my last thing is that I started the
Vlog and so if anybody wants to watch
anything watch the Vlog
are we going to be getting any cleavage
in the Vlog
no no
sometimes I guess potential cleavage in
the vlogs
we might be seeing some feet soon
hold the phone back it up record scratch
wait what feet are we seeing
um
from the shot today of spray tanning yep
oh dude you're putting oh that's gonna
be on yeah you guys can't watch me spray
my buddy
you look cool why'd you spray your feet
because you'll have to watch I guess you
got to do the whole damn
watch the video
you look nice I'm happy to report that
you still have
a perfect
hold up oh gorgeous feet five stars
gorgeous feet look at that gorgeous
exact number
somehow they know shoe size nine is that
correct
they're pretty good with some brands
they're pretty good you can't I mean
you're one of the only lasting survivors
from the great foot War oh that's a new
one from the Vlog you see holy oh [__]
and then these were the ones that we
made for c-man yeah
[__] awesome I forgot about the oh
pictures like that
that's so funny wait hold on I want to
look at the other one uh
who else did a foot everybody did one so
wait look look up mine do I still have
an account or did I no no you're banned
remember you're gone dude you're off the
hallway yeah you're completely we like
ruined the website I remove myself I
sent the email to get myself from oh
yeah I remember the drama you were
trying to pass me I I was oh it wasn't
but the fans were no he wanted it to
happen okay here let's let's that was
one of our first great conflicts yeah
and you know who started it yeah no Dan
was the one telling people in Discord I
was freaking oh yeah
so don't blame me a B for all this
conflict in our lives I sabotage UAB I'm
sorry
oh then open someone else's I want to
see more of these someone else's what
profile I want to see more of our
why did I say that you talk about like
the artist you want the seamance yeah I
saw somebody no no on wikiFeet
there's no way yes there is also I
didn't do one of those so I wouldn't
I just want to explain to the person
that was super confused by my comment
it's just because my the doctor was like
oh your uterus is gorgeous
joke with myself
I don't I'm sorry I'm not following yeah
that's fine the uterus is gorgeous
wait what happened
this one this is so psycho dude okay Sam
is on here Sam you knew I did know I was
on wikiFeet oh my God okay so Sam is on
here but uh the the c-man one that we
made isn't but look at this
yes and I watched that video back and it
is insane that someone got because it is
literally in frame for like a quarter of
a second and it's when I'm like finished
recording and I like bring my phone down
or something no it was um wow a video of
I was like cooking something or actually
I think it's when Olivia and I were
making the meat cake for Zach okay and
we showed um like a behind the scenes of
it yeah and that's what it was from
wow so why why aren't the glamor ones
here then I wonder you know I don't know
Somebody's gotta Sam did you do one it's
called no because I I made all the sets
and I was doing the I was doing the
other stuff oh so she didn't do one
herself so I mean
um who who else did one is Olivia on
there are you can we search for Olivia I
know I get did you do one Olivia oh I
did a photo for that thing I don't know
yeah we should look up the guys too I
hope not I'm trying to find it at my
feet I'm trying to find I spelled her
last name
I'm trying to find all the photos in our
drive right now so no no there's a
screenshot on the dance I spelled it
right
I want to see him on wikiFeet you know
what I mean the real well we can provide
them with we can provide the viewers
with them I guess right
you were just like so overconfident that
all of us would have Wiki Feats but you
guys do I don't I don't know you all
have Wiki I just sent the screenshot of
Dan like come on what are you talking
about stop it right um the people would
love to see a close-up of Sam's makeup
hold on hold on she did something crazy
Sam's makeup is so good today
Dan if you're on wikiFeet what are you
talking about Dan
look how beautiful
and you have a Beyond perfect score hell
yeah
what is this shot
I don't know you must have been from
some I I think we saw that and discussed
it before I think that that was you were
inevitable in a blow-up Castle or a
jumper yeah right right it was like it
ran it was like same as Sam it was like
one frame of a video where I was in a
pound this is Cam right that's Cam this
is uh is that Lopes no come on
I don't know if there's a there's an
obvious tell here that's gotta be um
Zach sorry I won't I won't die I won't
guess anymore
I don't know
sorry I'm sorry I'm sorry no my feet are
prettier than that okay I mean not to
say that Zach has ugly feet of course
I'm sorry
I'm not gonna guess you just tell me
that's me
okay Queen thank you
that's mean oh I was like who is this so
boring lame what is a weird angle my toe
looks massive oh it's in action it's an
action foot General yeah you're the
general I just I think my phone needed
some like uh
you know the war paint
sometimes yeah that would have been cool
if you need to doll it up then maybe you
don't have the best needed some
camouflage
get that foot in hair and makeup
that's mine that one's awesome this one
is so good
oh that's so funny
yeah wait whose is this
no nobody's gonna Fess out
Starkiller that's mine both of them are
yours
okay that's a great one I like the
creativity
oh see man eat your heart out yeah yeah
that's a good one huh oh yeah
oh yeah
whose is that
I'm not guessing
well we already saw cam so all that's
left is Ian or then and I didn't so I'm
gonna assume that's Ian that's Ian that
one's awesome too
uh yeah these are so good I was that was
such a great bit Yeah holy [__] I'm glad
we're revisiting because this this
deserves
a second life yeah but then so go to
where did Lena do one I can't remember I
don't think so yeah I was still a Teddy
fresh at the time
we need to get Lena's foot in a photo
shoot no thank you okay I now have an
account
surely there's gotta be probably nine
never show my feet well that's what Dan
thought that's what you think yeah I
really never like I never opened toe
shoes
rarely that's what I'm saying I think
then you never know
why are you worried about my wife is he
not on there okay okay Zach Lewis is on
here
[Laughter]
best
nice
back
yeah that [__] with no ass
[Laughter]
oh yeah as good as funny
it's just so not fair that all these
people have accounts except me
I brought so much traffic to this stupid
[__] website yeah yeah maybe too much
maybe that was the problem yeah nobody
going to Wiki fee without me they're
getting too much heat
uh yeah I don't that's the thing I don't
know if they
I think they maybe want to stay a little
low-key because it is a little creepy
this place and violated I mean you're
like you're bringing a lot of eyes to it
they may want a dark web stay low-key
let's see who's on top these days though
since I've been deeply is Hassan on
there
but let's see
it's on [__]
assign picker oh God he's like lots this
guy's like
yeah there's some people that take
pictures of their feet knowing it's
gonna end up here he's one of those
people yeah so no uh cookies for you
totally like seriously bro with this
shot
you're a [__] yeah he's a [__] he's a
giant [__] anymore
literally lying
dude right now come on what a [__]
liar dude if c-man saw this he'd come in
his pants down the his leg and the
grocery store it's a 12 incher but I
give it a light six
yeah
okay a little walk down memory lane
I love that
I do need to use the bathroom go ahead
thank you go ahead
so uh let's see
we've got
hey did anyone play the new Zelda game
other than me I did I
wasn't able to get it downloaded until
almost midnight so I only I played for
like an hour and a half or so but I was
enjoying it you said uh there was
something in it that made the combat
amazing is it the fusing is that what
you were talking about yeah because I
got that and that is when you fused the
big ass Boulder yeah and smashed the
wall down super fun yeah but that's so
the
the options that it opens up because you
can fuse anything it's [__] crazy
dude right
yep I I got past the tutorial Zone last
night and then I I think I'm almost done
with that because there's there were the
three things they tell you to do I did
two of them and then I was so tired did
you do that ice one
nope no wipes okay that one that one
well there's one on top of an icy Hill
and fire I don't know I feel like I [__]
it the game up to get there
like I was kind of stuck and then just
started climbing mountains in a
weird-ass way I think you're allowed to
do that now I know I know I took a
really weird way and I just stocked up
on like berries and I was eating through
the pain because you're freezing cold
what the [__] are you saying I say I I
ended the tutorial with like zero items
foreign
people saying spoilers this
this is the first like
30 minutes of the game there's nothing
being spoiled there's no spoilers
there's no problem [__] Savage you
gotta do it it's here here's a spoiler
for you
Zelda's in it
and the main character link
there's no spoilers I promise I wouldn't
do that
but I love I just I'm so happy to be
back in the world breath of the wild is
one of my favorite games of all time
stunning absolutely breathtaking game
and um
it's like that plus uh more cool [__] is
what I can tell so far
and um
I just exited the tutorial and I had to
I had this it was getting late so I had
to quit right there but
the whole fusing thing is like oh my God
it's gonna be so sick
you can basically you get this again you
get this in like 30 minutes so I'm not
spoiling stop
stop it
you can any item you find basically in
the world you can fuse it to any weapon
you have
you never know what you're going and it
looks crazy too it looks crazy and it
does crazy [__] it's so sick dude it's
so sick yeah I can't wait to play some
more tonight kind of minecrafty also
with the you can like build stuff the
building the sticking yeah it's fun
really awesome
yeah no it's mind-blowing
um does God know you're gay by the way
what
I have to bullying us okay I want to
talk about something
so tears of the Kingdom now I'm not one
of these people who's like oh they gave
the game a bad review so let's go ruin
their life or I know some Fanboys get
really crazy about it you think that God
Made You Gay I don't know why you're
saying that I'm just talking about a
Zelda I'm trying to show her how to use
it
proceed so it has like Universal claim
the reviews that I read everyone was
like this is somehow better than breath
of the wild which we didn't think was
possible
except one [__]
so who's who gave it a 60.
and again [__] socks they're boring
there's nothing wrong with saying it's
not my cup of tea but to give it a 60
that's a bad game 60 is a D minus right
emerging on an F yeah and the thing is
so if you if you've set foot in the open
world of Hyrule tears of the kingdom is
the best way to experience it just
enough new ground to keep things
interesting but if you didn't gel with
it the story alone might not be work so
let me read this review the first line
hold on
the second line third one yeah one of
these lines
24th line of the review right up top
okay the end of the review
there was some uh hold on hold on hold
on okay let them cook there's some
really annoying lines in here that I'm
gonna find
what is this review that person wrote it
or just some hater ass [__] from G
finity wrote it okay
um
is that these guys gave shitty games
like an 80. now even if you think it's
not the best game ever which is totally
entitled to give it a D minus is insane
like the the scope of the game the
Polish of the game
the yeah everything like you got it like
you can't really give it less than an 80
like let's say you just it's not your
cup of tea you think it's over hyped and
80. 60 that's just bad faith
you know what I mean and and I I just
think it's it's [__] lame do you
think they're maybe just
rage baiting uh clicks 100 like just
doing it to be contrarian and they'll
get a lot of traffic 100 100
like six out of ten I mean that's what
you give like is there like a summer
yeah let's see what they have to say if
you've yet to step foot in the open
world of high rule through the kingdom
is the best way to experience it with
just enough new ground to keep things
interesting but if you didn't gel with
the 2017 the story alone might not be
that doesn't sound like a 60. like that
summary doesn't really say anything that
bad hold on I saw some really bad
I'm sad to say that tears of Kingdom
just isn't worth the wait for me
personally okay sit but like [__] you I
mean you know you're right the world
doesn't uh revolve around your whole
world life you know what I mean I mean
it's just one critic you're just mad
that it messed up the perfect score on
Metacritic is that I just think it's
lame to do this it's not a 60.
it's just not I mean I mean they might
genuinely hold that opinion and it's
just a bad okay then okay then let's do
this this is where I like to see because
if let's go to their other reviews
and see like what they've placed in
their top reviews of all time and then
you'll see how obsessed this is this is
gamergate too this is the real gamergate
right now this is ethics and journal in
gaming journalism gone awry I don't even
know how to navigate it how do I get in
gamer dead Mark with that one how do I
speak other reviews let's see
um
maybe someone can help me because I'm a
dumbass
reviews oh here you go other titles okay
now what now what what are you looking
like one of them I just want to list
like a t like uh
you know or maybe on on here if I click
their ass I can see their other reviews
God damn it click their ass imma click
your ass you can click it in the article
John
so
um how do you feel about people that say
that this one is better than the first
one no I was curious where what are your
thoughts well I haven't played but
but I believe them because it's like the
same but better more stuff going on
um I believe I mean listen I loved the
first one I thought it was a masterpiece
so yeah I
loved the first one so much that I
wonder if the second one is better
I mean that seems to be a consensus and
again it's not that I'm
here here we go look at these guys okay
now
let's see
buy a Metascore this is their page right
Divinity original sin great game wait
I'm confused no I think you yeah just go
back you were at the right place those
were all the reviews from the same
publication highest
I'm confused
me too I don't get this I don't
understand this [__]
um it says this is gfinity score but it
says they gave it a 90 oh critic score
it's the it's the second number that's
what's confusing about it the bottom
number is what their score is okay so
let's see
the top number is the overall score the
bottom number is what they gave it okay
okay okay okay let's see so uh does
anybody know of any shitty games that I
can uh dunk on them
[Laughter]
it looks like they pretty much went with
the crowd on every single one yeah no I
think this is a big deviation this one
seems to be an outlier this this dude
just I don't know 60 though
maybe they just got dumped last week and
they're in a bad mood give them a break
just saying like they almost don't even
give out 60s you know it's almost
unheard of Gotham Knights God of War
Ragnarok hundred
okay chill it wasn't a hundred I liked
it I was in a hundred
give it a 90.
you know what I mean [__] idiots dumb
asses
what is this Jeremy from the quartering
ass uh rant you're doing right now
listen I don't know who I'm not I don't
care about the gender of the author I
didn't even look at the name
what was that what gamergate was I don't
I don't even really know I
don't know and I've purposely kept it
that way for like a decade now it's like
that we'll never know I don't want to
know what the [__] gamergate is I don't
care yeah
that's one that I luckily
dude they hated Match Point Tennis 30.
Fair
it's a tennis game come on I mean yeah
it's probably pretty bad
there's some fans of that game who are
pissed at them for that
all right all right we're lost we're
lost yeah we're in we're in the meme
hole that's not hot just saying
okay I'm saying it's whatever but anyway
yeah it's I'm excited to play it nice
you know what I mean
yeah okay when everybody plays it
plays the thoughts about the Graphics
because
the first one I immediately fell in love
with because of the graphics funny it's
gorgeous gorgeous yeah yeah and then
with this one I just don't know so I
think the problem is that it's on I'm
playing it on like a 85 inch tube oh
it's for sure the TV but even when I
look at it on the handheld it's not that
different than the TV also the starter
area has really weird lighting what is
with the collar skin why are the
characters so orange and everything is
so orange and yellow
let me show you when we get home tonight
because now I'm back in the normal game
area where the lighting wasn't all crazy
and do you I didn't I barely got had any
time to even look at it I just saved
so oh Dan's opening oh Dan is playing
right now oh can I see you brought your
switch with you to work
well I don't know I thought maybe if you
like went off on a Godfather ranch or
something or something to do
can you turn it around so I can see the
graphics
but then I can't play
I mean talk about this
I mean actually I guess I could I guess
people some people are saying that they
agree with me no I I mean again in the
listen uh Mr Leo saying gameplay is more
important than Graphics to you
I watch it and play I don't play it I
enjoy the visual I see and that's fair I
loved
in the first one and the second one
definitely it listen it's the same
console with like a what a five six year
difference so
I just realized I want Taco Bell right
now
wait wait let me talk
like something everybody give this man a
round of applause right now you know
what just it was so weird the sour cream
on the taco supreme just hit me hmm that
is really weird absolutely some neurons
just fired off in the wrong direction
than you are Ethan you trying to get it
yes Alfredo send her whatever you want
thank you for the validation the chat is
agreeing I thought it was going crazy
last night because I was trying to love
it so bad I was like okay maybe it's
just a cool face I mean it was just
weird lighting to start and then it's
gonna get better but it was just like
that it's kind of weird that was the one
thing that I was like the graphics
outside in this weird lighting but
tonight when we play back on you know
back in the the normal world
I was running in a lush green field it
did look beautiful yeah you know
in it
what do you want from Taco Bell
what do I want I had a burrito right
before the show started
hey this is whatever all the haters say
this is me right now this is me this
weekend
all of you hang gliding is so funny to
me I think you should do it
say whatever the [__] you want I'll be
gliding through Hyrule
this is me right now
mm-hmm having the time I don't want my
hands they're so bad
what are you AI
by the way I have half of my burrito in
the fridge if you want what kind of
breakfast burrito I'll take a look at it
okay
you're not gonna eat it no well I do
want Taco Bell though I don't want to
take that away so don't yeah
so forget about it okay damn I heard you
ninja chill Tyler am I Jewish somebody
somebody get this man a sandwich
somebody take their bra off and get this
man a sandwich so it comes down
um I'll get uh let me get um
I like their burrito the beanie cheese
burritos are pretty killer bean cheese
rice burritos there so simple the simple
one yeah no that's a standby what do you
eat there Dan cheese quesadillas uh they
have this uh potato taco like a Chipotle
potato taco wow
yeah and then I just get like the bean
and cheese rice burrito that I got or
whatever that one's good yeah and uh
whatever I'm feeling they have a black
bean uh Crunch Wrap like one of the
crunchwraps it just doesn't have meat
you don't want to try any of that anyone
want a boba
I would also like this Friday I'll take
anything I'll go for a bowl right now
okay one thing at a time
Boba too we can do both
oh man
all happening
all right so get me um I like the Taco
Supremes get me two of those
okay you're gonna go to bed and you're
still gonna be if I work taco supreme
it's done cream and a taco soup that one
and only item for me over there and a
bean rice and cheese burrito
I can't say I'm crazy about the dillas
so boring the kids idea
oh basically racist
I pronounced it correctly I was probably
more racist when I was calling a
quesadilla
quesadilla Yo Taco Bell fun thank you so
much uh celo Mexican pizza I thought
they discontinued that they brought it
back
I thought they discontinued they brought
it back I can confirm of course that
must have been a whole scheme because
let's be real everybody loves Mexican
the Mexican pizza is the McRib of
Mexican food
you know what I mean I do unfortunately
yeah it should not exist
if that's it shouldn't exist and but
everybody loves it and they it's always
coming back it's always coming back did
it ever really leave it never really
left because it's always it's back the
McRib it's back
whoa is that then or Seinfeld over there
what's the deal with this what's the
deal with the McRib it's here it's gone
it's gone if it's always coming back
are there any 16 year olds in the
audience oh no
what's the deal
on here
you guys had to run it what's the deal
with age of consent in California I
can't date a 16 year old
but if I go to but if I go to Louisiana
I can have sex with a 15 year old what's
the deal what's the deal with that is it
okay or isn't it okay
I'm gonna button your ass
16 is the age of consent well he did I
think she was 17 to be fair
I don't know I don't think it really
matters that much he did date a 17 year
old yes which is crazy that like he was
just out in the open just like here's me
and my girlfriend who's 17. that's
stunning and we as a society back then
were like cool you know who's never done
that though
Larry David King
he's the real King he would never no the
Real Genius
I do wonder what Larry David's sex life
is like though it tastes like beef jerky
because he's just such a weird guy you
know
such a neurotic and weird yeah yeah I
feel like you get it kind of like
watching curb like he would turn off
Everybody by his neurotic
mess you know right but by the time it's
time to get to anything you'll be so
annoyed with him
yeah he actually I heard a great bit uh
I think this was in real life not on the
show somebody asked him
when you're dating are you afraid that
women are just how do you know the
difference if woman's just like likes
you or likes you for your money he's
like
he's like I expect him to like me for my
money that's all I've got going for me
if she didn't like me for my money then
I'd be worried right I was like that's
fair
love that
[Music]
all right so like what did I get claimed
last time yeah two tacos Supremes and
[__] they have so this weird stuff I
want to try the weird stuff
yo you're in trouble
what's a weird thing to get I like their
ground beef what's a weird thing to do
dealer's Choice Sam some weird ass
[__] ground beef
got it a chumpa Lumpa
oh God
if you like ground beef I've got
something for you
your toilets blessings will humble thee
what do you get when you're squirting a
poop
ground beef stew
[Music]
what do you get when you're on the value
stack on the value menu
a big fat diarrhea
attack
good content here on Friday
you did say we have a good show today
and this is what you're talking about
right there was that estimate all
different flavors uh let's move on we
have actually have some fun Goofs and
gaffs actually a lot of them
let me do the good doctor though because
this [__] is too bad and Eva can vouch
for me
I've been I've been wondering what the
[__] this show is for however ever thank
you forever every time I don't know what
show is it that it always like records
Bachelor okay that's what it is so it's
always like a little tiny bit of that
show and every time Ethan can't stop
talking about what is this and you're
never really receptive like I'll go on
but you're just you're not entertaining
me to the degree I need because I felt
like almost like I'm missing something
because it looks so insane and I was
like I don't know I don't know what this
show is
I needed answers but I will you know
what I mean no I am a surgeon I am I'm a
surgeon I am I am a surgeon I have a
surgeon Dr Hunt I have a surgeon now
obviously I I don't watch the show but
the context is even crazier what is it
apparently he's being discriminated
against
because of his
autism okay
and he's apparently trying to
he's trying to argue that he's fit to do
his job but he's clearly not he's
clearly very just he's not fit to be a
surgeon
he's not a surgeon and apparently he's
the bad guy who's trying to be like yo
bro you can't you're out of control
now I'm on doctor I'm on doctor's side
here I don't want this dude performing
on me
I mean I don't know is he like a genius
when it's time to do the Yeah Boy
surgery well apparently but I saw
another clip when he had a freak out and
he took off his mask and gloves and
started coughing in their open canvases
the coughing part
very beautiful
yes in fact
but uh
you know
page Dr Lim keep her stable
there's no audio
oh
it's it's fixed you're fixed okay
so that's what I'm saying the man ran
out of surgery and listen I've got
Tourette's I'm not trying to be a
surgeon with my shake you know what I
mean I'm not trying to do a scalpel on
someone while doing this it's just not
it's not for me
um
right
it's not ableist
I don't know I don't get the show
um
apparently they're blocking Clips what
[__]
they're afraid of the truth man why are
they trying to afraid of the truth
watch this Hilo
what's up
[Music]
what is the show sir
he's got to save this kid now and uh I'm
not a doctor every everywhere this guy
goes people are exploding just falling
off buildings
it's so good uh but there was really
good
bro what are they doing they're actually
claiming Cliffs that is so whack these
people are
out of their [__] minds man
so disappointed
here's some edits
all the time
[Music]
he's right though I'm actually following
the plot here this man is completely in
the right
take a rocket surgeon Ethan no it
doesn't
I am a surgeon
what is this edit
they made it a little more watchable
what is this
it's for the Zoomer
oh my God
well it's kind of ruins the fun we're
blocking all the clips
but listen to this the scene is taken
from an episode
called breakdown in which Dr Murphy
confronts Dr Han after being excluded
from taking part in a major operation
the plot of that episode is Dr arm
believes Dr Murphy's autism could
jeopardize the procedure
but he was eventually fired in part due
to discriminating against his
colleague's disability so they fired Dr
Hahn who saved this patient's life
and then they put the good doctor back
in there so he could rip off his mask
and cough in people's open orifices
doctor is one of the highest
most watched U.S network shows seventh
season
this guy
[Music]
a lot of [__] what I am I am a
surgeon and I'll tell you what they all
vote
they all vote have a surgeon Dr Hunt Sam
do you have any thoughts on this they
put it right after the bachelor that's
what it is so I think that people are
just like forgetting and they're like oh
[__] this show's on and then they turn
it off so I feel oh so that's why it's
the most watched yeah I feel like it may
be the most watched because people don't
even realize it's on right now for like
major shows I feel like yeah it comes on
after Bachelor and I want to say maybe I
think it's Bachelor maybe it's American
Idol or something but it's like a major
Network show and it comes on after it's
Bachelor I think it is Bachelor yeah
well we always watch about Usher on uh
the DVR if it wasn't DVR I would 100
watch it
I see thank you I would watch that whole
show for sure
the lawyer with OCD is his buddy what's
the spin-off
here read this comment because that
sounds like go ahead read it okay the
show is ableist
I'm autistic and find it so cringe feels
like he's just mimicking autistic little
boys and no one involved knows what
autism is right he's not autistic the
actor is not autistic and that is really
annoying to me too
yeah oh people are saying audio what's
the audio issue
I'm working on it what does it sound
like though should I wait is it badly
died oh it's gone oh it's actually gone
well tell me if it's gone so don't keep
talking into the void
yeah well
you're back I see
with audio she's also died
so uh it's back people are saying
so apparently the spin-off with a young
lawyer with OCD like what's the spin-off
are they homies these girls will just
like chill together a doctor with OCD a
surgeon with autism
and they uh
and a podcast hosts with Neo is slightly
delayed
thank you [__] loud poor then didn't
you just spend a lot of time fixing
everything yep yeah worked on it all day
yesterday streamed for uh 18 hours last
night no problem
we got to replace this computer yeah and
we just got it like two years ago but
this computer is like completely wait
did you get the new video card I did oh
that didn't fix it we're having problems
right now
500 some of you have to protect no one
gives a [__] about you bro dumbass
computer dumbass [__]
uh here is the actually and one of the
comments
what does that and for people say it it
genuinely doesn't have anything to do
with the button it has to do with the uh
with the main vmix computer it's not
button related smash that button it's
not oh okay
uh in the coming episode actually
the good doctor goes on trial for uh
vehicle or not vehicular but uh
negligence and and manslaughter
here he is
yeah he nicked someone's arteries and
they bled to death because he's having
an autistic freak out into the jail
yeah he goes to jail that's all that
series is that season is super crazy
you know how does the good doctor act in
general pop
done this show and his character just
looks like
mature totally like
she's I don't think that that's what he
would actually be like she's steals if
he was a surgeon with autism that's not
that's not what it is he would be
professional he would be it's like how
people totally fine do a caricature of
Tourette's totally yeah
just yelling random stuff right like
Mark uh the guy from Nexium
yeah screaming the n-word on the bus
yeah which can happen can happen but
that's not
what it always is so I'm just curious
what other members of this uh super
group we have the lawyer with OCD the
doctor with autism uh the orthodontist
with the
with the bipolar
we've got the uh
the chiropractor with uh schizophrenia
but schizophrenia that's that's kind of
a fire show
you know he's so he's such a talented
chiropractor but he's got like he
sometimes just goes through hears voices
yeah and there's so much on the line
when you're adjusting people
did I show the story of the woman who
got uh
completely paralyzed from the neck down
after a neck adjustment
I don't know did you
I don't I don't remember if I showed it
to the people or not we just got a 10
donation that said the good doctor is a
pretty good chef
really I mean
it has a lot of fans like Ethan said
it's one of the top rated shows in the
country so
somebody likes it well I'm looking
forward to the chiropractor with
schizophrenia personally
I'm personally looking forward to the
podiatrist with PTSD
from uh
from the Iraq War
somebody said no somebody said No Lie my
dad is a chiropractor and he has
schizophrenia yo yo
audition oh
yo let me buy the rights yeah
yo I can see the um the podiatrist with
p with the PTSD he's sitting there
looking at someone's foot and then he
has a flashback and then the foot is
severed
he's holding a severed foot because he's
a flashback to Iraq war his homie got
blown up and he lifted up his foot like
that and then he starts screaming you
can't you can't tell if it's severed or
if it's the real foot
mm-hmm that's good talk about the
alligators they call it the good
podiatrist
uh Goblin these nuts uh donated and said
real people with Autism could do all
sorts of important jobs very well
neurodiversity needs real representation
played by real neuro neurodivergence
love you all I agree if there was an
autistic person that was capable enough
to become a surgeon and get this job
they would be totally professional they
would be uh you know what I mean they
wouldn't be having freakouts and I I
feel like from watching Love on the
Spectrum I've like learned so much about
what people on the Spectrum can actually
be like and seeing this show it's like
so far from what it is
right
yeah I'm looking for I'm looking forward
to the the one about the urologist
who uh
oh I have it he's closeted
that's funny you're all just as a penis
doctor oh and he's a closeted gay band
that's good do you want to twist real
good just imagine that dude that's a
[__] fire dude
yo so he's he's holding in someone's
[__]
right he's doing some kind of test and
then he has a flashback to college when
he was he was uh bicarious
and he's holding his homies [__] in his
hand
I don't know
it's called Dick that's good it's called
the confused urologist
oh man I can't hear people are saying my
friend had this on all night when I was
over my mom loves it I will never
understand
the grip this show has on people that's
what Dan and I were saying yesterday it
seems like such a mom-core show like
moms will watch it
'd be like oh this is so heartwarming
are you screaming did you hear about the
spin-off with the um gynecologist
um what what about him uh he has
he has elephantitis in his arm
s
[Music]
man just look at this
you can imagine how difficult that job
would be
foreign
that's really interesting
it comes on after um
America's Got Talent so it's a good slot
good time slot
[Music]
yeah
wait a lot fall lineup yup must see TV
oh [__] all right let's get to the goofs
should we order Boba by the way we
didn't decide on that one so I want one
that doesn't have a lot of sugar so far
they've all been like insanely sugary
let's try a different one just like what
do you get Dan it just looked like a
regular Ass Coffee yeah I just get
coffee Bobo with the coffee get a coffee
I got Dan that's what I want it was an
Americano with Boba so can I read it
Americano with oat milk
and oh and boby's oh Bobby yeah
and I'd probably I don't want those
lattes squares or whatever the [__]
espresso coffee jelly no coffee jelly
yeah whatever to get here no I just want
the same as I had last time do you have
it you want the watermelon or the honey
yeah yeah that shit's insanely good fire
that one's insanely good but it's just a
little I just try not to have a ton of
sugar you know yeah for sure it tastes
like candy
this was a really fun post I'm curious
what you guys think which table are you
sitting at okay
um I saw this
so let me let's see so we have just
Pokey and and idubbz well that's a great
table there's nothing wrong with that
table I definitely they were sitting
there look that's not the whole table
oh oh it's a bit okay yeah yeah
I thought they were all benches yeah me
too Ian does have the best table though
I would say I would pick his because
yeah keem's there but that's the only
bad one you can overpower DJ Khalid is
there yeah
two Ian's Pokey the thing is keemstar is
such a repellent
yeah but I feel like there's a lot of
good going on here it keeps her such a
lull cat you could totally make fun of
him he's wearing a full stand shirt what
a loser such a pick me
he is that's it that's what Teamster is
yeah what is he doing with his hand
looks so weird a little West Side I
don't know west side or what
what's that about baby
West West New York Western West Buffalo
Northwest New York State baby it's
Buffalo the only thing he's west of
is a linear line of consent age of
consent
starting at 18.
and then here all the way up to like you
know so the x-axis so he represents the
east west west side he's always on Lower
ax he's on the lower end the lowest
possible end the right west side of the
consent access
that's a that's a banger joke right
there you know you know okay so
that one is a good option but keemstar
is pretty heavy let me see the table
with love antenna because love antenna
is awesome love Tanner Bryce I like them
all sure Will Smith that's kind of a bad
Vibe but Bernie and that these guys
bring the vibe down so bad
maybe with keemstar you could kind of
like just everybody in the table kind of
like meme on him right Teamster can be
fun yeah if he's not in like a total
psychotic like rage but then those two
guys are just gonna be yelling the whole
time like actually angry right well
coconuts and Barbados is Chill when he's
not under a bad influence yeah I don't
think he would really be talking he
wouldn't say anything yeah sure I would
love to see Bernie debate with Myron
though oh my God bro that's
you don't want to subject him to that
okay that's fair but it's incredible how
much Myron brings down the vibe yeah
yeah absolutely and then we're going up
here we have me and post
and then Tate and wow Hate's the only
one that [__] that one up yeah Ninja's
fine PNP rules the Bradleys are great
the Bradley the bradberries yeah Nina
sucks
right he's a bad Vibe a little bit of a
bad Vibe so dumbass
he's probably gonna try to get the whole
table to floss or some [__] sounds fun
it's pretty bad that's pretty much like
him alone might make it yeah
I know the situation is fresh and fit
it's so smart
who's worse though
somehow I feel like Myron would be even
the worst because he like Andrew at
least is like
he can be funny he cares he can be
charismatic yeah Evan has no redeeming
quality yeah
he's pretty awful here
this one's actually this table is
actually pretty good I think Joe Rogan
Olive Oliver A B xqc I mean that's fine
Aiden is a sweet boy when he's around
you he's not gonna do [__] you know what
I mean but he's sitting next to Rogan
Rogan again also Rogue is not gonna do
[__] either he's just a little he just
follows the crowd and Dr is will keep
everybody in line This stable rules I
could not disagree more this is probably
the worst table for me why
[__] Aiden Ross show Rogan Oliver
like this is the most annoying human
beings on the [__]
planet's at the table I'm not saying a b
baby and Dr IDs are fine but I got four
I got nothing to do Oliver tree the dude
is such a [__] pain in the ass I can
see myself vibing at this table I'll
probably talk to xqc be like people
don't understand you either huh oh I see
you guys can I yeah
this one is for Olivia why you do that
to Olivia we have Olivia Wally now Chris
from preyconvasion that he's clearing
out the table yeah that's pretty bad
that might be the worst Vibe person
there yeah yeah dubrick bad vibes you
can go for your eye it's not safe all
different Hassan Jimmy Lee I would I
would I personally would sit with Jimmy
Lee no problem my son and Jimmy is kind
of a funny combo chocolate mocha yeah I
feel like Hassan would try debating
Jimmy or like yeah give him like a
serious lecture on yeah
although we have done that yeah it's not
crossing over with those people could
actually make that pretty interesting
right ah but the Chris the Chris Monroe
yeah
prank invasion
okay this table uh is really bad oh man
this is the worst oh
won't say anything so that's kind of a
non-factor
it won't say anything but that face I
don't know the face the face cures
cancer literally
it's the gays of Miracles
what happens if you have like prostate
or
rectal or prostate cancer does he stare
at your butt hole
can you get on your back and show them
your [__] gaping [__] and he just
uh I don't think it works that way the
healing property flows from his eyes to
yours
um window window windows it's the window
to the soul yeah right right right right
right
yeah
all right right does anybody know where
our bronzo like giant poster is
have you seen that lately
ever since the Flocka photo I took it
home I just look at it every day no no
I'm kidding it's somewhere here it's
rolled up
what do you mean Kim
he's talking about Boba oh
yeah let her know
yum is my favorite bunny man um but so
liver King is like terrible I watched a
report on liver King last night NBC News
some like profile they did on I fell
asleep right did it get good no it's
just just that he's fully back he's for
sure back on steroids he's back on his
annoying dumb ancestral [__] he
stinks as a [__]
so and then Jordan Peterson is just God
awful I mean my God and then Jeffree
stars and my parents you know I I no
your parents are good your parents and
Zach great that's a fun comedy yeah but
these other four are well no they're
nothing more about so but these three
I thought this table is actually pretty
good too to be honest
so yeah papa John who is uh he's my dear
friend
Howie is the best guy ever lean is
awesome yeah Dan great yep the
quartering again like they're
contentious but also weird best Steve
Vibes also yeah
I feel like we could talk shop me in
quartering
right like maybe we could get him off of
the
fans on some topics no no mostly we
probably talk about like
[__] in weird spots yeah strategies
right and then Wendy Williams is she
would join that card yeah I feel like
this table rules like I really don't
have a problem I do like I mean Jeremy
obviously but I I don't know I don't
think I would have fun like sitting
there and bantering and making yeah
Jeremy so right it's not really a
detractor the thing about Jeremy is like
as disgusting as an inbred loser as he
is like he's kind of harmless in a sense
yeah yeah
I feel like I could hang out with Jeremy
to be honest and it would be like fine
yeah
as long as you don't bring up some
topics
like ordering is a low IQ inbred loser
their favorite sound but ever cue inbred
loser
and Wendy's awesome I mean I've paid
yeah so that might be my fave table but
not here this I wouldn't even want to
highlight table I'd say let's let's eat
outside today Gabe let's go take a walk
yeah this is a problem this is not a
good table no I like Joey salads I mean
obviously he's like
you know yeah Joey salads but he's
actually a nice guy to hang out with
which we've done many times very
pleasant he's a little before my
viewership time so I really don't know
much about his Lord I think he's a giant
piece of [__] okay terrible views but
nice person he's really not crazy yeah
fine to get lunch with yeah yeah he peed
in his old moth he peed in his own mouth
oh yeah he did that he uh pepper sprayed
got pepper sprayed in the face for the
sake of our show uh which actually got
him banned on Twitch right
um oh it was a nice little twist to that
did you guys ask if Taylor wants
anything
you did okay good
I mean James uh Ty Lopez Tai Lopez is
killing it for me is it
Ty would just really ruin any [__]
conversation he was in I feel like
dude James Charles at a high school
lunch table horrible though oh get him
out of there
that's true
that is true that's your problem
uh coming up here we've got this is
interesting table although I have to say
Logan Paul is in a medium Vibe killer
for me yeah and
I don't know well he's a good
conversation one says we've we've
learned sure
uh Beast is great to hang out with he's
a good guy Ela I think Steve will do
it's a nice guy in person like we talked
a little bit I think yeah he'd be he'd
be totally fine to kick it with I don't
know I feel like Sam and I would just be
staring at each other like can we switch
tables we have each other
Logan is the Logan's the only one here
that I wouldn't really want to hang out
with which I guess isn't that bad for
the whole table oh my gosh
fousey alfredo
Kyle from nelk
Britney Phil Brittany and and uh Bradley
this table's not bad yeah
not a bad table no so which is the best
table do we think
[Music]
um
I I think I'm sticking on my own I think
I'm happy right where I am you like your
table yeah I like my table too
you wouldn't mind sitting down with the
Freshman fit dudes
it's not about like liking the people
it's more like the entertainment volume
I feel like it would be fun Sanders yeah
I mean that that tempts me to want to
sit at that one but I kind of like my
table too it'd be interesting to meet
face to face with tater tot and see what
a [__] he is in person
I'm seeing mostly mine and Lena's table
or Alfredo's table those seem to be the
two favorites yeah Lena's table was good
it's weird everybody likes their own
table
no no no not everybody
and so because Lena and then are at the
same table right which is a pretty good
table
and love
um I hate my table
this isn't that bad it's not funny I
just well there it is it's pretty bad
it's pretty bad I don't think so well
okay do you want to switch seats
with you let me see your seat cams is
where's Kim that's the one with nickel
hi Lopez
I think Ian's table is pretty good too
yeah I think Ian's is the best well
there it is we we've put it we've put
quite a lot of thought into this
and the top comment is Papa Howie Leena
Dan quarter and Wendy's seems to be the
preferred table there
yeah
so congratulations
to that table
shout out
you can't sit with us okay then my new
favorite cool table you can't sit with
us Ethan I like my table I'm [__]
nerd I didn't want to sit with you
anyway where's your where's your tray oh
my favorite [__] food up into your
face my favorite comment was I'd be in
the stall cry next to Bryce Hall oh oh
sad all right my new favorite insult
just dropped okay this is Nick Fuentes
the loser Nazi that was traveling around
with uh with Kanye with Kanye
he's such a strange guy well apparently
according this video he's getting into a
physical altercation
after being called a come Hunter
for attempting to locate remnants of his
roommates ejaculate after discovering he
had sex
so I did I didn't know this but
apparently Nick Fuentes is an install
like a Oh serious one his one of his
homies lost his virginity no it's not
well
this is there's blurry lines of course
but it's because he's super Christian
it's like no sex before marriage kind of
thing yeah you don't got to worry about
that right but like it's not like an
incel it's it's uh what do we say it's
it's volcell it's voluntary it's all a
bit yes so anyway one of his homies had
sex and then he was going around with a
black light looking for splooge
and then his homie called him a come
Hunter
and that started the fight it was to
come Hunter
isn't that funny
you [__] come Hunter
and by the way Nick Fuentes who's the
biggest loser unfortunately
that's a good question look at his look
at his goofy yeah what is this
he's wearing he's wearing the Yeezy Gap
jacket and these giant [__] dumb like
venomous boots
God you look stupid how old is he 24.
it's all dumb anyway here's the come
Hunter Nick Fuentes
don't [__] touch him stop
sure look at those boots outfit is
terrible how are you real bro
Kanye did you dirty man yep
so Nick come Hunter Fuentes I love that
it's fantastic shout out to the come
Hunters
shout out to come Hunters everywhere
you know they don't get the respect they
deserve absolutely not
uh there was a great Karen video that
dropped
very good and and fantastic it starts
with her running over which is awesome
she's she's just running over okay
um apparently they're just chilling in
their car enjoying a view of a lake and
this woman comes running over
here look at this
they're not even driving it's like
they're not even trying to leave
probably the T10 then
it has a T10 that hustle is super
impressive yeah
get it get it yo look at yeah
she got her hands that's what I said it
looks like the cop from uh Terminator 2.
it's so she's more aerodynamic runs you
know less drag
1000 DPI
this is a do you have a permit to be
here it's going to be done in business
okay sir we pay a lot step away from my
car sir step away from my car why do you
care just [__] yeah just Just Do Your
Walk
it's a private Lake
he says what do you want me to do for
you and then whoever's in the passenger
seat says we should leave this one seems
crazy
that's true my American tax dollars pay
for my permit oh hold on hold on okay
you're American tax dollars okay so it's
not a private Lake then because
apparently if you want to do it the tax
game I [__] own that Lake compared to
your ass probably
that's my [__] like Beat It scram
lady
this is a private like y'all don't look
like you're supposed to be here um
whoa whoa is she saying that you're not
American
is that what she's saying you ain't no
American taxpayers around here only
American tax papers allowed to enjoy
this year leg
I tell you what man I ain't I ain't let
anybody who ain't why as Wonder Bread
come here enjoy this Lake of ours
I'll see way too much colorful come
around this beautiful Lake here now oh
not here boy American like you you look
like European whether you come from
Poland you come from Poland or Russia
but to call the police the police
I'm about to call them police and I'll
tell you these boys they're good old
boys they don't take kindly you're type
Round Here
tax is more than your whole salary get
out of here okay no don't stare at me
sir hey hey don't you just touch my car
oh my God babe just go just go just go
just go just go it's like an empty lot
too like
what did she say oh my God he hit me oh
my God the man did not even move his car
hey
he's saying this pig
s
that's fair no don't stare at me sir hey
hey don't you look at this oh my God
just go just go just go yeah
completely fake wait what yep
why do you do why don't you tell me
before I play it I didn't know the chat
everybody in the chat recognize this is
a comedian wow I feel like a broken
record every time I say but
immediately notice it's fake yeah I
don't know uh brought me so much joy
gosh darn it it's not that obvious it's
not like you get to [__] like
celebrate on us dummies you know what I
mean well uh
yeah I mean it people just recognize
again I just sent the Instagram for the
for the lady
she's a comedian this man says this is
stage let me explain why fat people
don't run like she did for nothing
that's not necessarily the best
explanation for why it's fake but uh
what do you expect from somebody with a
blue check mark the check mark is
basically a Nazi Flair that's my theory
at this point you know
yeah speaking of blue check mark uh
there's a new CEO of Twitter and and the
blue checkies are very angry
did you hear about it no I don't yeah
you're a [__] hypocrite Elon hired a
woman
who according to the blue checkies is a
wokey
yeah sure she's just a blood-sucking
capitalistic freak well so this is
what's so epic about it was he does he
open until now yeah yeah okay so
literally everyone is mad about it
because the reality of this person
people went and found their Twitter
profile and looked at all their likes
and they're liking all kinds of like
election denial and like uh you know
right wing with the woman yeah wow huh
yeah so people on the left are like oh
this is like a total like ew that's
gross but then what's beautiful and this
is this is why elon's the best man this
is why he's such a genius he could have
picked anybody in the world and he
managed to thread the needle in such a
way that he has literally everyone mad
at him about it it's so [__] funny
because this person is also an executive
at NBC
woke trash bad whatever and
is a part of the world economic Forum
which is a group that all the right it's
the globalist Communist agenda like that
those are like the people that's the
great reset like that's Enemy Number One
to these people he's an election denier
yeah wow
so so
yeah somehow somehow in in all of his
genius he has found the person that
could manage to piss off literally
everybody on the platform it's
love him well anyway
about that but I guess I Gotta Give It
Up to the Caucasian Arab who is the
woman who was running towards him at t
uh
at the Terminator speeds so that was
great then good for her comedy a bit God
but what the [__] it seems I mean it
seems real to me I mean I've seen Karen
videos like that boy you know what I
mean
this was a great moment for her
[Music]
what do you want yes roll down please um
no this seems real I don't know what I
mean
yeah
well done yeah
I love the idea of fake Karen videos
like as a genre
uh I have a whole bunch of Goofs but
maybe we should talk about the Twitter
thing since we're on it yeah so so Elon
uh made a tweet
this is from
May 11. so yesterday
so I did announce that I've hired a new
CEO for X Twitter what did he mean by X
slash Twitter oh [__] yeah he renamed
the cup the the corporation is called X
now because it's [__] cool and badass
he already has a business called X space
SpaceX right
but X is the most badass letter
it's in porn
um
it it seriously changed the company name
to X slash Twitter no he just knows that
nobody knows what the [__] he's talking
about if he says X so he says Twitter as
well but the the company is technically
called x-corp or some [__] oh it's just
co-founded x.com back in the days it's
the it's PayPal before it was PayPal oh
there you go so it's a it's a throwback
yeah yeah
okay so anyway he says
uh she'll be starting in six weeks my
role will uh transition to being
executive chair
and CTO
I love that he's made himself CTO
what does CTO stand for
technology officer technology
which at a company like Twitter you
would assume is pretty important
um
so who is this woman
maybe I should steal one from you go
ahead yeah
turns out to be Linda
yakar
yakarino
who's CH the advertising chief for NBC
Universal
and you can tell what he's trying you
just wants someone who's gonna make a
profit
she's the advertising Chief that's what
she does
yep
outside of work
uh let me get a picture of her Mrs yako
miziako
next it's going to hire Wacko and Dot am
I right shout out 90s kids here she is
Ms wacko the Yakko
so yeah she's heavily involved in
initiatives including the world economic
forum
task force on future of work what she
heads
she's also a chair on the board of Ad
Council a non-profit group that helped
uh
help the group raise 60 million in three
months
early in the pandemic to help counter
vaccine hesitancy
right so she's she's pro-vax
I'm telling you this woman's an enigma
but how is she anti yeah I don't know
100 herself this is why Elon is such a
king for picking this person that is
just like the weirdest set of beliefs
possible that's like fine-tuned to piss
off everybody it's awesome he's the worm
so she
is pro-vaccine great
good job
um her Org the world
economic forum
promotes the concept of the great reset
which has been a right-wing Boogeyman
over the last few years
wake the [__] up
the world economic Forum in an
international non-governmental lobbying
organization
based in Switzerland
founded in 1971 the foundation is mostly
funded by its 1 000 member companies
typical Global Enterprises of over 5
billion
oh so she's New World Order is [__]
exactly exactly like the the the world
economic forum is like Enemy Number One
to people that are concerned about New
World Order Illuminati [__] like they're
all they're going to make us live in
cages and eat bugs
um
all that kind of stuff
as well as public uh subsidies
globalists
it views its own mission as improving
the state of the World by engaging
business political political academic
and other leaders in Social Society to
shape Global Regional and Industry
agendas wait I thought the great reset
was some weird conspiratorial [__]
well so no I mean it it was a it was
like some talk that the head of the Waf
gave a few years ago about using the
coronavirus economic crisis as an
opportunity to reset the global economy
in various ways or whatever they did not
they read into that yeah yeah
yeah and frankly you know it probably is
a lot of bad [__]
um but not not involving Satanism or
drinking baby blood or anything like
that a lot of people interpret that as
like white genocide or something
they they yeah the white genocide stuff
a lot of overlap with like the Q Anon
type stuff it's just you know
you know how those things go at all turn
the freaking frogs gay he said it just
he said it best didn't he folks
this burrito was so like low quality but
so good I know what you mean
exactly what you mean
um
so
cat turd which is a superb
um
cool guy
super reactionary
freakazoid
Nazi Flair just verified
responded to this announcement
Elon Musk the woke mind virus is a
threat to the world also Elon Musk I
just hired a far left alone deeply
infected with the woke mind virus from
Twitter
Twitter 2.0 was fun while it lasted get
ready for it to suck again
35 000 lives
oh yeah now they ain't happy they ain't
happy with Elon
um here's a video
of her interviewing Elon just a short
time ago his fans are not feeling this
kim.com there's a name I've ever heard
in a while mm-hmm oh my God
you see us right-wing Freakazoid yeah of
course or Liberty super weird
he's like Heart Like Giga libertarian
basically
so here let's see what clip is sending
them into a frenzy so you've got a
massive platform
you have a vision yeah you turn it up a
little bit is a spectrum of just daily
open sourced conversation
they can conduct their lives their
business their Commerce whatever they
can do on your platform that's a pretty
big honest with those but but in the
middle should be
um advertising opportunity that sounds
like a great opportunity I can talk
about my brand I can get my customers to
communicate and then they could also buy
stuff it sounds pretty good right you'll
be able to buy things just directly on
Twitter One Click Boom done yay that
sounds so fun I can't wait for more
products and [__] to be sure right and
that's that's the real irony is it's
like
oh this far left loon it's like
she she's a business executive that's
like focused on Advertising it's like
she's
as capitalist as they come oh yeah
mm-hmm
but they need to feel I think him hiring
her just shows how desperate the
situation is
yeah just straight the person who's just
focused on marketing and business you're
in charge of the whole company now
you're the yard right
yeah that is that is telling isn't it
there is a an opportunity for
to influence
what you're building that Vision what
we're doing here whether it's me trying
to push and prod you uh on your tweets
um for example you've said uh you
probably shouldn't tweet after 3 A.M
well I've got probably good advice for
all of us
I love that I kind of like that she's
already been like yo if you want me to
work for you you got to stop [__]
tweeting crazy [__] because if I'm gonna
go secure all these advertisers every
time you tweet out some vaguely white
supremacist thing right
we're gonna have a problem myself into
trouble a few times
I'm I'm very aware of those
um so after 3 A.M
you travel all over the world the Lord
knows how you handle time zones in space
you commit to be a little more uh
specific and not tweet after 3 A.M
people in this room would would like to
see that and then what she really means
is you kind of roasted him people in
this room would like you to shut the
[__] up yeah
it's funny she says 3 A.M it's like no
you mean like vaguely white supremacist
[__]
we're doing the Ouija board
I've seen this he gets a little
defensive here I will aspire to tweet to
less after 3 A.M but I mean it is
important that guys you know I mean if I
were to say yes you can influence me
that would be wrong
that would be very wrong that means that
would be a diminishment of freedom of
speech no it's not you dumb oh my God
you're just dumb she's literally asking
you as the owner the single owner of the
company
to [__] care about it like freedom of
of speech doesn't mean that anything you
say is going to be a good thing or a
smart thing you're gonna say some dumb
[__]
it doesn't even make sense she's asking
you not to say dumb [__] because you
have a lot of consequences
this this argument is insane like the
right wing has this concept of free
speech that's like so
perverted
it it
they think that Free Speech means saying
whatever you want all the time and not
being held accountable that's basically
what Kanye was trying to do with the I
love Hitler right and well Kanye
approved you can you can
say whatever the [__] you want yeah but
don't get surprised when nobody wants to
[__] with you anymore it's like you own
the company how is that a violation of
your free free speech you [__] if you
want this you can finish it
but I want to be specific about
influencing it's more of an open
feedback loop for the advertising
experts in this room
to help
develop Twitter into a place where they
will be excited about investing more
money product development and safety
sure content moderation that's what the
influence is yeah I think
it's totally cool to say that you want
to have your advertising appear in
certain places in Twitter and not in
other places but it is not cool to
assist to try to say what Twitter will
do
well I just ask you to stop being an
idiot
what are you [__] talking about
you're such a man child right now look
are you trying to tell me what to do
because that's not cool well he still
hired her
do you think there's like a backhand
deal with him and his other companies
hiring her because she has so much like
seems like a weird hire almost
or what do you mean backhand deal
no no him benefiting somehow other than
just having a good hire I think he just
wants a shark who's gonna try to make
money somebody he has no other option
probably somebody in the chat said Dan
look up glass Cliff it explains why he
hired her and I Googled it and said
glass Cliff bro we can't play it it's
cursed
should I not is it curse
refers to a situation in which women are
promoted to higher positions during
times of Crisis or duress or during a
recession when the chance of failure is
more likely but simply women setting
them up for failure Epic
is that that could be an element of that
but also it could just be a panicked
thing because I genuinely think the
company is in huge trouble like it is
bleeding money and all the reports like
the Twitter blue thing they seem to be
counting on because they lost a [__] ton
of advertisers which is where all their
money came from and they were banking on
the Twitter blue thing being a hit and
everybody correctly pointed out how
cringe it is and all the reports that
I've seen like they're making like
let's they're making like a million
dollars a month from 20 million yeah
like a few million it's nowhere near
what they need so
I think also that he probably doesn't
have that many options for who to hire
right I don't think a lot of smart CEOs
would want to work with him yeah it's a
it's a it's a bad career move for a lot
of people yeah that's [__] up
right
so I think the pool that he has to
choose from is pretty limited between
like somebody that knows something but
all is also a q Anon
like it's got to be some kind of a bad
deal like that
she makes no sense her her philosophy in
the world using advertising dollars we
lose it
but freedom of speech is Paramount dude
she
this is so cringe
you being able to use tweeting racist
[__] she didn't say we're gonna you
doesn't make sense
it's so cringe
it's like
why it's like why are we clapping
it's just becoming a broken record of
like freedom of speech everybody clap
she goes please just don't tweet slurs
anymore
are you trying to violate my freedom of
speech it's like you own the app you can
say whatever the [__] you want on it
also he's just totally [__] full of
[__] with the freedom of speech thing
because I've been seeing this you know
the whole like Twitter files thing was
about how like it was a scandal that
Twitter
took down dick pics of uh Hunter Biden
because
people should have the right to see his
his with them or whatever uh
apparently
Twitter since he took over they're
complying with government takedown
requests more
than the old I mean we felt it firsthand
when we were just goofing around and
they sense like they censored both of
our accounts
Twitter has complied with at least
partially uh at least partially with
98.8 percent of takedown requests under
Elon Musk ownership data shows which
again just shows the conservative
interpretation of free speech means
being able to say slurs with no record
right yeah
pretty much
so I can't believe you got clapped for
that Twitter 1.0
had a uh very well populated much loved
influence Council I know I don't uh I I
think we need to change the name Elon
does not want to be influenced but it
was really a recurring feedback he's
like this dumb he's like this super uh
egotistical dumb dad who like won't hear
anything so you have to like make him
think like it's his idea
child Man Child yeah child
gloop from your key stakeholders your
advertisers where they had recurring
access or would have recurring access to
you
would you commit from this stage did I
just realized there's no sour cream on
that [__] taco supreme oh [__] that
was the whole reason this all happened
there was no sour cream on it
I was there I have no idea I don't
remember
oh no not the crying Jordan
why is the sauerkraut a big deal that
was the whole thing that got me remember
he had the intrusive thought where he
was like I need Taco Bell sour cream
got it yo what the [__]
I gotta say the Pete the Mexican pizza
not it
I've ever been it I don't get the love
for them and that's a controversial take
I know I really enjoyed though the
burrito and the taco those are way
better yeah classic why you gotta get so
weird with it like
I'm not taking a pause just [__] all
over the floor
[Laughter]
I think there was cream by the way there
was I think so
it didn't satisfy my itch
are you pregnant you got an itch for
sour cream oh
[Music]
I don't think I am maybe I started
taking your hormones yeah my medicine
today
to reinstate that Council
to be named later well I don't think it
should be
influence Council that
because I would be worried about
creating a backlash among the public
because the public thinks that that you
know they're shut up [__]
you know a a small number of CMOS in
America they will be like I think upset
about that
um but feedback I think is appropriate
um and
you know at the other day uh if
somebody's spending money for their ad
campaign it needs to yield results for
their organization or or it doesn't make
sense
genius the analysis wow you can't really
see he's been drinking the Kool-Aid yeah
I'm only worried about what his fans
would say yeah when he said the public
backlash what he means is the cat turd
guy like cat turd is going to come on
here and yell at me if I do that which
is funny because he spent like what 55
billion dollars to acquire a marketing
uh a company that makes it's all of its
money from Advertiser dollars he's so
[__] disgusting
weird like how can this guy be so dumb
right now when I thought he was so smart
here's kim.com he said the uh wef
Associated future CEO talking about her
of Twitter promotes influence peddling
for advertisers and content moderation
that makes advertisers comfortable we
know what happens when you give
corporations and their political power
puppets over content I don't like this
pissed off about it there you go
um Elon fans are not happy uh again
because the world economic forum is
basically a Satan worshiping
communist organization
there's more of his fans
conspiracy Twitter is melting down over
yet Reno's connection
involvement to the world economic forum
let's see breaking Twitter uh Twitter's
new CEO Linda
yakarino is currently the CEO of the
world economic forum and was chairman at
advertising at NBC so they even need to
analyze it it just speaks for itself
it's so disturbing
what is I'm not following they're just
saying she's the CEO
our chief
executive chair of the world economic
Forum that alone
yeah again it is scaring them yeah that
organization is is the devil to these
people so any connection there is big no
no [__] you Dan
I'm right
um
[__] you Dan
these are all pretty good
if she gets the job I will end my
subscription no don't do it
flare because we definitely don't have
to add money
oh no right there's only people actually
paying for this [__]
wait
did he cancel it you look up Fred DB and
see if he canceled his [__] oh yeah I'm
looking it's rewind time we gotta hold
him accountable make sure he canceled
his [__]
you know
hold their feet to the fire
uh Wendy also a Nazi Flair check mark
says that breaks my heart I've submitted
my application I worked so hard to
rebuild my account to move it to
monetize
with my goal and I thought I
accomplished it and now this what is she
talking about
she's trying to get him on it like you
can monetize your Twitter account or
whatever
yeah they're like heavily pushing it for
creators saying that they're going to
get a big cut of Revenue they've been
saying that for like a decade like video
stuff yeah
Twitter's been trying to get me to do
that [__] and like it's literally
nothing there's nothing no money there
you actually did notice that many others
will feel exactly like you but Elon will
still be the owner and on top of things
so hopefully things can still get
corrected I love the Fate they have on
him he hired her guys
uh look at all these Nazi flares man
that is disappointing automatically
disapprove of weft Agents yeah fox in
the hen house uh oh
I'm convinced that all data on all
social media platform smartphones and
stuff are collected in real time to
train their AI the real II the public
doesn't know about
Jesus is red mm-hmm
wow we're all missing here is Pfizer
connection I think I'm canceling
no don't do it we gotta check on Oz
Trooper
you better cancel that [__] don't let me
down now
well it won't disappear immediately
right because it's subscription this
just happened like today so right to
anybody yeah if they still have it
doesn't mean they haven't canceled
look at this homie I had joked earlier
that AOC was the new CEO of Twitter but
unfortunately I would have preferred her
over Linda really oh let's do that then
at least we could have had Twitter space
screaming matches with AOC
this is true that Elon Musk has pulled
up the biggest psyop in modern history
idiots
you can see what was in front of your
face the whole time bro's got that check
mark too in it
you're paying for it yeah dummy
it was good while it lasted this would
be the I've been Psy opt this would be
the rug pull of the Year this is bad
it's so cool I love it they're all
khakis I love it yeah it's fine it's
phenomenal I'm being so hot
no
it's kind of giving me the Vibes of like
the people who ran into the Insurrection
and then they're like right oh [__] we
actually committed a crime what I'm
being arrested for this
presidential if you see
you all I did was take a dump on Nancy
Pelosi's desk yeah
that's my god-given free ride
uh he's literally wearing okay so now
we're cutting to the chase finally
people are reading into what's really
going on here this is his profile pic
this yeah this is elon's profile back in
this armor okay he's literally wearing a
Baphomet suit on his uh Twitter profile
does that not tell you something
remember the implants in our brains he
is pushing does his support for
transhumanism raise a red flag
that's why it's never made any [__]
sense to me that these people like him
like
he's just because he says freedom of
speech yeah the freedom of speech but
it's like you heard that he said freedom
of speed he couldn't give off more of
like evil evil mastermind billionaire
Vibe if he tried like bad boy bad boy
what you gonna do I did see some like
Ultra freak uh conservative uh
fundamentalist turning on him when they
saw him in this armor
it's got some like demon on it
not good Elon is what is their reference
is it like a video game thing or just
for fun
the armor I think he just did it for fun
it was a Halloween costume too yeah it
was a Halloween costume or something oh
okay Sam is just straight coffee
but they always [__] with me
I don't think I'm ever gonna get the
drink I want from boba
oh there you go oh that looks good there
you go they're just I guess yeah just
pour it out though because it's right
third one yeah go to the bathroom again
um
yeah people on the left are not pleased
either I want to see some of these uh
likes she's got about conspiracy
[__] oh she's a
posobiic loving Trump conspiracy Nutter
too how did she how can she Jack put
this guy yeah
how does that how do these Jive I don't
know well because her personal beliefs
you know
maybe one thing but at the end of the
day she's
you know she's an advertising executive
so
she can understand that
loudly tweeting about this kind of stuff
isn't good for
the business that you represent or
whatever but
yeah I don't know
so she liked this tweet do you guys
remember that time the FBI found a judge
who worked for Epstein to sign off on a
raid of Mar-A-Lago
but
okay
you're pretty in the weeds there bro
what's their name I don't know the [__]
you're talking about
is is it just this one tweet
oh no there's another
there's another uh link there
I only see one link here at number five
one second
Ian
Ian Ian Ian Ian
Olivia please stand up
America
oh I'm sorry scroll up in that in that
tweet there's another one there and then
I have another one that for some reason
got deleted here it is yeah it is a
great guy here's another tweet she liked
uh Thomas Massey I don't know who that
is
laughingstock Arizona election process
elected officials responsible for the
Arizona election process
I don't is that election I mean it was a
mess there wasn't it
well I think
can bound with uh the other ones thank
you Dan yeah here apparently
apparently what we love Puerto here we
go
thank you oh yeah that looks good thank
you Puerto Rico apparently she was
liking a bunch of like she's a big fan
wake up pray up
uh right there was that other one
anyways you get the idea she liked this
woman saying if we're going to teach
kids about fire and how not to burn down
their homes why don't we teach them
about tech and how not to burn down
their souls is she is she Christian
yeah probably okay
burn down your soul
sounds cool to me
so there it is
lots to look forward to again on into
Twitter Saga
as uh it continues to burn down
we love it don't we folks I do we love
it I almost don't use Twitter at all
like I straight up just use it for self
promo now like I just don't care and my
timeline is so gross
unusable I hate I just hate it I used to
laugh so hard scrolling through Twitter
yeah Twitter was my fave for a long time
it was the best
tick tock's my favorite now yeah Tick
Tock is all that matters Tick Tock is
our home just reading is so much easier
than like having to listen to something
half of my feet at this point though is
just hoof yeah no it's all cleaning
stuff yeah on Tick Tock oh on Tick Tock
okay all Health cleaning just cleaning
are they ever infected hose yep I've
seen those it's like my whole feed I
even got so deep I went and subbed to
the guy's YouTube channel incredible and
which because he has longer full videos
there it's called the Horse
the horse GP
if he's coming at you yeah this guy's
the best he's in like Scotland or
Ireland or something this guy's the
king of um
of the horse hoof of horse hoof cleaning
he's the [__] man dude let me pull
one of these up
ugh
gross it is so crazy watching them like
scrape back at where a rock got lodged
and it's just like damn that must hurt
so badly it goes so deep in oh yeah he's
having to like walk on that for so long
I mean I don't know what it's like to be
a horse to be fair no these poor cows go
through a lot and um
I don't know I don't usually like gross
stuff like pimple popping and I [__]
hate that [__] but then when it comes to
cleaning these cow hose boy I'm in
but hey all over the mark there's no way
we're getting it all
can we not they're pretty
well this part's not gross he didn't get
to the weirdest part it is a sharp knife
I promise is this really gross this is
too much for you um
okay GPS out I can find a less gross one
you lose out
here I was looking at his most popular
these ones aren't gross at all actually
this one's not gross at all this is 21
million views this one's not gross at
all
he just takes a nail out but there's no
blood or Gore or anything
[Music]
look at the difference
yes so
this poor bull had a damn nail in his
disgusting in his foot
you're a bunch of [__]
cows are so interesting creatures
they're just so
milky I don't know
so truly they're compliant I don't know
yeah they don't care if they're stuck in
like a giant machine and some dude just
scraping into their they actually do so
the machines are crazy they have they
lift them up into this massive
mechanical thing and each four of their
legs are restrained so they're like
floating
like this cow is fully [__] locked
down it's crazy
uh really
I don't know why you guys are not tough
let me just find the part where he takes
the nail out
and maybe it is a little
graphic
which is not for everybody
yeah I don't know what it is man it just
hit me different I love me some cow hoof
and [__] but
I'll tell you what but I love ain't
nothing like ain't another life boy I'd
be a farrier I'd be like out on there
dude where they work is [__] gross
because sometimes they'll be cutting the
cow hoof and the cows they're just
[__] and pissing all over them hmm
and the floor the surface where they
work is just caked and [__] and pissed
it's so gross there it's so gross so
gross that is [__] nasty and this
dude's getting like [__] squirted on his
face and he's not even slowing down man
it's the real deal
all right let's do One More Story Boogie
of our swings of redemption I promise
some keemstar
uh and here it is okay Boogie's boxing
what
you like that I do not like it what are
you Misfits is the guys who keep putting
on these um
events that are super dangerous that
like
I think Ian was always like
they're like head butting and biting
each other it's like crazy yeah I swear
I think Creator Clash is the only event
where they actually the promoters
actually care about the fighters I got
invited to be on Misfits like two weeks
before a fight with the dude who's a lot
bigger than me right basically needed a
Fall Guy I remember that and you weren't
even training at that point right nope
they're just like come fight this dude
and get killed for no reason
I didn't take the clout and it was a lot
of clout I was surprised you didn't take
it because that's a big crater that he
used to watch what were they gonna pay
you I'm sure they would have
because I don't think it's that big of
clout I would just be more concerned
with getting paid because you just show
up some dude just beats your ass and you
know I mean like you would look you
would look like an idiot well he ended
up fighting
someone else really big it's just about
to say who it was well I don't why can't
you say who it was I just don't want to
say it publicly he beat the other guy's
ass right no he lost the other guy oh he
lost yeah but the other guy is like
KSI
so the other guy's KSI about KSI yeah
the guy you were gonna fight fought KSI
that's it's so that that tells you the
matchup
and I don't think it's anything on the
fighters I'm not even blaming him it's
just whoever's setting it up is okay
with just being like yeah find someone
try this guy or try this I think just
has like a list of random people
so anyway the main event at this is
going to be KSI versus a business man
Joe
I mean what
the [__] is Joe farnier
this is the main event
oh he's a professional boxer
do you know who this guy is baby no so
apparently he's fighting this guy and
whatever that means I don't know
but that's not why I care Kim's
promotional company happy punch is part
of the event Kim is taking credit for
making the fight happen here is keemstar
promoting the big one this is keem's Big
Moment Boogie first wings of redemption
and keemstar in blackface
[Laughter]
that's horrible
what is going on
you know I found the timestamp and I
really could not tell I was looking at
it for a while
I think this may just be
turned down a little bit some black guy
who posted it uh that's his Twitter name
he's a nice guy I've met him I know him
uh he's someone said there's no way
that's not edit he said I swear it's not
find the video you can see but yeah
that's racist bro I don't I don't care
if it's just a shadow or bad lighting
even if even if it's edited or whatever
even if it doesn't it's not actually
that dark just pull up the photo again
Ian let me see it look at his arms look
at how little of his face you can see
yeah he's in Disguise
he felt like a cartoon that disguise on
secret agent undercover yes so insecure
literally will only show his nose and
lips
and he'd cover him if he could but yeah
you're good he didn't have any options
oh my God yes so literally a three-man
crew on this stuff right
this picture
when it's more like that it's just a
black figure
why is it so like if it's not why is his
arm so dark I I feel like the It
Happened find the video I don't think
it's edited the video is actually in the
dog it's in the dock I don't think it's
edited they're wired uh came asking uh
Boogie why he's getting in the ring
let's take a look
and it's finally finally happened there
buggy uh to end this thing out if you
could get up here do a face to face with
wings
we got we got security ready
you know that
yeah the facial coverage is wild yeah
it's wild
I mean you know what's interesting is
people joke that it grows the pointy
beard out too
look villainous whatever he's actually
just covering more of his face right
right he's covering his whole neck I
mean I look good if I could cover my
whole neck too not true just all of it
well
no
there was a race to the center Wings won
that
yeah and I mean in terms of boxing
events this wouldn't be considered
probably a responsible boxing event
would it uh according to the article I
write the heaviest boxing match in
history is that right oh this is tense
here we go
I didn't know wings of redemption went
so did you break it did you drink one oh
[__] he's actually quite a bit taller
than Boogie
they're just doing that Sumo bumping big
man you're a big man
do not do not me oh my God the prime out
of nowhere hydration
[Music]
[Laughter]
nope
this fight as funny and silly as it
looks is gonna be unwatchable I mean
they're not I'll be watching I'll watch
it I'll I'll watch it it's not going to
be a good fight though they'll throw
like one punch and then be gas I mean
huh
oh my God
I have actual fans up there you know who
watches you
laugh uh Boogie I don't know if you know
this but the crane look at this bro I
could smell his breath
you know Boogie's a fallen fan I do know
he went like full Fallen fan I mean he's
hanging out with Kim Star right
sure is I guess so that happens to the
best of them hang out with keemstar one
day
what happened why is keemstar producing
the show
you're actually showing more face than
him I mean uh we tighten up a little bit
if I pull this down yeah cover yourself
just always want to find treasure yeah
that's that's right
That's my boy
all right let's do it who watches you
people watch you to laugh that's who
watches you I have actual fans of this
audience right now
[Music]
um
Grange not sure about that
where they sponsors at huh I don't need
them Jordy I don't live in a [__]
Trail
I don't live in a [__] Trail I don't
need a spot
wait
wait so these guys are actually dishing
some trash sock here this is this is
it's spicy this is high energy yeah
sure I see
we're gonna get him out of there ladies
and gentlemen
boogie2988 versus wings of redemption
hype he goes well Boogie went to jail
because of him right no that was a
different guy wasn't it yeah
oh my God I love how boogies like people
only want you to laugh at you I actually
have fans there's three of them in the
audience right now
there's three people that like me
game Boogie went like full reactionary
Fallen fan
although to be fair I don't blame him I
mean it's like the Ali London thing I
mean you gotta find friends where you
can oh
where he's talking about why he took the
fight I think he kind of explains why he
uh sold his soul that came
where what oh there's another one yeah
tell us more
go on Face Off
it's getting really hot wait hold on
where it's getting so hot what number I
gotta I gotta stop because uh someone
tell them what number I don't have the
dock open that's a good point then maybe
it doesn't get enough oxygen oxygen yeah
from all the coverings
and maybe that's what happened to Kim
maybe he's got brain damage yeah
I thought that's what I was just
watching
all right
and it's finally finally happening
Boogie uh to end this thing out if you
could get up here do a face-to-face
maybe it's time stamp to run
let me go back to the beginning
this is the whole video guys
I got you hold on
I got you I know where it came from
do you have your passports did you get
your shots
I feel like dog [__] right now
[Music]
yeah definitely to talk about I had one
taco
half a burrito yeah and a few slices of
Mexican pizza I mean it's not that bad
that's not a lot that's almost what I
ate and I had half a burrito before that
okay I think it's approximately right
there okay that's the beginning
talking about the Boogie fight
you've all been waiting for this is
YouTube history these two yes it is
um were some of the first creators on
the entire platform YouTube was founded
in 2005 and this man boogie2988 started
in 2006. his opponent Wings the
Redemption started in 2008. these guys
have been around for over a decade
what's the wings of the Redemption or I
have no idea it's really interesting
yeah you you're gonna have to watch like
internet historian or no no what's the
guy who does the super long video essays
he's a really good one
it's not him I mean internet historian
does do that maybe it's not him it's a
it's a different one
um Sony V2 yeah he
hmm
um it's uh the entire internet
t-ro everyone's saying
tro no Frederick nudson
is that what you said what no down the
rabbit hole he's the series down the
rabbit hole
this guy [__] rules he'll he doesn't
put out a lot of videos but they're all
like really in depth and they're so good
they're all good man
uh really good so the wings of
redemption one is really good it's got
nine million views he's like one of the
old school
YouTubers who
uh he came up playing some Call of Duty
or something sick juicer he was just
such a self-destructive train wreck it's
really interesting it's all so old
YouTuber I didn't know anything about
him either until I watched uh that video
but it's a good watch I recommend it
two hours long I watch the whole goddamn
thing damn yeah
nothing a little different
the entire world said that this fight
could never this mashup I think is good
because they both
the background is really interesting and
that's why I set it up that's why I
tried to make it happen
um there was so much against both of you
going into this the entire internet said
Wings you never get on a plane he did
get on a plane he is here
it's like the mic's not on he's just
screaming in a big empty room I had to
turn up I'm like maxed out on the volume
on every
everything I can it was caught okay yeah
Call of Duty one of those old ones he is
also here buggy tonight yeah
[Applause]
this is 800 pounds in one ring Boogie
why did you decide to do something
different with your career and take on a
fight like this well first I just want
to say to Jordy thank you for taking on
this 1v1 I know you're not a big fan of
them uh thanks for coming out of
retirement to do that I mean you say
this but I've never backed down from a
1v1 okay oh yeah yeah all right but what
I just wanted to say that um
honestly I kind of needed the money I if
if I had not whoa whoa whoa didn't you
just make fun of him for being broke
he's like your ass lives in a trailer I
don't need no advertisements he's like I
did this because I need the money
uh thanks for coming out of retirement
to do that I mean you say this but I've
never backed down from a 1v1 okay oh
yeah yeah all right but what I just
wanted to say that um
people that know the lore are saying the
1v1 joke is actually good
so shout out Boogie okay shut up Boogie
got him with the 1v1 I guess if you know
the lore that made sense it's deep deep
lore yeah it's good though wings of
redemption down the rabbit hole and
nobody else has seen that
no no this is the first I've ever heard
of this guy
honestly I kind of needed the money I if
if I had not done this fight I might
have ended up living in my car but dude
what the [__]
this seems healthy yeah this whole thing
yeah it's very healthy I don't feel like
there's any way he's getting more than a
few thousand bucks for this right AB I
mean
I don't know it's completely different
you guys did for chairs yeah but
I don't know but at least you and I will
both have houses with wheels on it Jordy
so that we have that in common you know
you know at least my house is paid for
but but oh
because I think Boogie was begging for
money because he said his house was
about to get foreclosed on that makes
sense okay here we go the Jousting is
happening I'm here for it keemstar's
loving it I just I'll be honest with you
man I keemstar reached out to me not too
long ago and he's like dude let me pay
you to get fit let me pay you to change
your life let me pay you to get your ass
out of your rut of misery that you
created for yourself
he said that to you it's a little harsh
let me get you out of the rut of misery
no that's boogies and I took him up on
the opportunity man and it's taken six
years after my bypass surgery to get to
this point it's taken I cannot tell you
how much therapy how many psychedelics
like I've gone through hell to get to
this point
and I I will say here's the thing that
jordy's really got to deal with okay
he might win by decision but there's no
way he's put me on my ass I can promise
you that I've taken worse beatings when
I was eight I've seen a flight of stairs
give you a beat in the day
okay wings of redemption the banter
isn't bad I guess that is good man [__]
me
all right but then
you you know you're the favorite going
to this fight you got the height on me
you got the reach on me you got the age
on me you got everything else but I win
by being here do you understand that
okay Jill you're hedging your bets a
little too hard already this is so
depressing
it's like the kind of depression you get
after like two days in Vegas
um
I know exactly what you mean by that
you just walk through like it's fun
exciting and you're drunk the first day
then you sober up the next you walk in
the casino and you just see these like
these people are just like you could
almost visualize their souls being
sucked out of them into the slot machine
I'm here okay man well well yeah but
he's basically saying I'm going to lose
for sure
I've had a severe laugh you already lost
this is your oh yes okay chance just
like so many other people chose to ride
my coattails
I guarantee you got some pulled the
phone buggy whose Road your coat tells
hold the phone
to write them one last time man you know
your career ended because you refused to
go on a camping trip and soon you're
gonna be living in a [__] tent wings
are you gonna take this I mean it's a
lot of talk from from Boogie but the
internet and most people think you have
an edge here
how does this change your fight are you
really going to take them down round one
oh I'm trying to get him out in 30
seconds
like honestly like yeah like he's got
bad knees he's got no hips he's got no
movement he is it is legit very
dangerous I mean when Boogie came in it
was before his bypass so he was a lot
bigger yeah but he he was in such
terrible physical shape and pain
um
well it was a whole thing just to walk
down the hallway to get to the office
right and he's a bit Fair bit older now
too I mean how old is he buggy 2988 age
duties 48.
I think Boogie might die
I've had a severe lapse in judgment and
I want to post that's not what I'm
hoping for for the record of course not
yeah sorry
murderer
what yell but he basically murdered him
on the other hand could be indirectly
responsible for another YouTube's death
roll it
so that's kind of a cool idea over the
what three beat at hat trick nobody's
ever had that hat trick
wings of redemption age this man's 37 so
he so Boogie's got a cool 11 years on
him
and those are 11 Hearts those are hard
ears honestly Boogie has no chance
just seeing seeing the two of them even
just standing next to each other you can
tell like like honestly have you seen
the weigh-in shirtless no well I'll show
you that do you guys have that it's
pretty interesting I've seen a flight of
stairs that they almost take this man
completely I wake up you already said
that joke bro in more pain than you're
gonna put me through do you understand
that that's see that's not a good
endorsement for you
I wake up and
I wake up in more pain every single day
enforce trauma I'm a man uh-huh yeah
um Boogie you had mentioned to me in a
Twitter space you said you know you're a
nice guy you don't like beeping with uh
people normally but when it comes to
Wings you know that's someone you could
really slap around and punch him hard in
the head what makes it about wings that
you don't like them that you're ready to
get in the ring and really do some
damage man I'll just be honest with you
I'm done treating him like a person he's
just an obstacle in between where I need
to go and what I need to do an obstacle
dog I've seen you busting down sweating
getting interviews over there
full I'm gonna sweating okay I flew 20
hours I got off a plane I came here wait
flew 20 hours where'd you come from
is this maybe at a layover wait is this
in is this not in America
I think it is overseas in the UK okay
okay yeah KSI is fighting okay fair
enough that's exhausting I'll give you
that
here
it's a wheelchair six years ago Jordy I
was in a wheelchair all right oh God
it's not you know
this dude how many elves can you [__]
take
I think I'm a little sour On Boogie just
because he became so Fallen fan on me
yeah well me too like he he went so wild
I said one little thing about him being
a fence sitter and he like lost his mind
and made like I don't know 100 H3 videos
he's like or I don't know the exact
number but he's like
prominent H3 Fallen fan hater
I mean if you can do a if you can see of
any recent ones with funny titles or
thumbnails I'm down I stood through two
hours of interviews that's pretty
goddamn good oh my Lord you were in a
wheelchair you're gonna be in a
wheelchair Sunday it doesn't matter you
just oh yeah yeah you know I destroyed
my wheelchair to make sure that I didn't
need it a lot of people said I should
do wait wait wait wait wait wait wait
wait wait wait wait wait you did what
hey you know I destroyed my wheelchair
to make sure that I didn't need it
it's just it's crazy to me that Boogie
thinks that Kim star is doing something
good for him by by getting him involved
in this you know what I mean this is not
good for Boogie yeah team star only ever
uses people yeah you'd be a fool to
think otherwise yeah
he destroyed his wheelchair so he
wouldn't need it yeah he destroyed his
wheelchair like as a will power
situation thank you baby we're not
advertising for people they don't want
that anymore to burn them
I don't need this here wheelchair no
more you're not gonna need that and then
I like he's like some people said I
should donate it but uh-uh a lot of
people said I should donate it I know
who's going to hit the airport
he doesn't even defend it he goes a lot
of people said I should have donated it
anyway
saying that they can push you along you
just gotta tip them
shorty you're a joke you're a joke a lot
of people are tuning into this you know
it's a laugh all right there's one
person to laugh at there's actually one
low cow here I'm root YouTube royalty
You Are YouTube never was I might dude
this is I can't watch this
what is a LOL Cow by the way you don't
know that expression I mean I've heard
it but I'm not 100 on it it's somebody
who's uh who's so embarrassing and that
you you milk them for laws oh so they
they are a constant source of
you know okay being embarrassing yeah
got it yeah and was the website that um
kessels went to war with was that Locale
uh well that that term sort of
originates from like the oh that was
kiwi Farms yeah yeah that was kiwi Farms
but I think I think an earlier version
of that site was called like at Loco in
the name or something I don't know yeah
um uh Christine Chan is uh
with sort of the original ball cap it
has been that's all got it that's all
you never were brother you know it's
funny because you used to talk about how
you were so smart investing your money
and we sit here today and you're a
penniless you're taking a fight against
a man oh yeah there is this thick Boogie
like lost all his money in crypto or
something
just such a great story
uh what a
it's a it's a Redemption story wings of
redemption story
and is 15 years younger than you you
have no chance against me 11 bro 15
where'd you pull that out fight with a
man who's 15 years
you can't do anything to me my mom
didn't do to me when I was eight bro
chill stop trauma dumping
[Music]
I mean it's just you just make you know
what I mean like damn time and place
buggy it doesn't look like Boogie has
any reason it was just the ones from a
while ago okay he got mad at you there's
a lot of deleted ones there's still like
threads on it
but he apologized to me his my apologies
to Ethan video not real not even I
didn't even know he made that I it's not
really a Napoleon yeah I was going to
say I'm pretty sure oh is that ironic
thing it was yeah but that one is up
hold up let's watch it um
not worth it he starts it by saying I
know a lot of people don't like this guy
yeah the vibe killer
well that's how that's how you should
start a video about me yeah
Wings what did you have to do to prepare
for this fight because you know even
though you think it's going to be easy
you haven't been training like it's
going to be easy you've been putting a
lot of work and effort in can you talk
about that well like there's always
there's always a puncher's chance in any
kind of boxing match you could make one
mistake and you know momentum take over
and you can get put lights out I didn't
want to get embarrassed and I was in
terrible shape when I took this fight
and only had like six weeks to actually
get ready for it and I don't I'm not
gonna pretend that I'm a boxer in any
shape or form but I dropped 36 pounds
good for you I basically
six weeks
that's great
I wasn't allowed to touch the gloves in
six weeks
say what
I'm allowed to touch the gloves oh the
Wally method no all right it
well since I've been here in London you
know I've been trying to stay on top of
everything I've kicked soda for the most
part I've been watching for the most
part I'll take it to you all right
before you can get them yeah two more
things taking multivitamins I mean this
helps not the Maltese I mean you could
have been doing that do people usually
talk like this before a boxing match
well I've been like kicking the sodas
I mean neither of these people are
athletes this is definitely unusual yeah
I've never seen my mom abused when I was
eight I'm on my vitamins I promise
there's some straight up I wake up in
pain every day my mom abused me when I
was eight years old
I started taking multivitamins
for the most part
I take the chewy ones because they're
easy and I like the way they taste
I only I'm drowning drinking two pops a
day
my life but you know uh uh rap uh bunny
steps or whatever they turned around
because I was in a bad spot heading over
what do they say baby steps I like well
bunnies yeah there's a bunny there's a
small creature I like biceps
oh God the pun is intended for this
fight this is redemption okay if you
walk away with a win win
oh [__] I don't really know about that
answer I'll take it to Boogie same
question what changes in my life no
changes I keep that's such a bad
question what changes in your life from
this inconsequential stupid little
boxing match getting better I keep
getting stronger I keep sometimes aren't
that [__] deep right perfectly stated
oh my God
that's crazy
just an old picture of teddy
can't believe how different he looks
people
no shut the [__] up
I've been on a path since I've been on
YouTube in 2006 my first video was me
eating french fries I have lost 200
pounds I've gotten my Mobility back I've
entertained millions of people four
million subscribers and that just number
is going to keep going up I'm gonna keep
doing everything
here's the weigh-in so you can kind of
see
their physical prowess
just size them up
[Music]
391.
[Applause]
[Music]
my boy in the doctor oh no that's Rogue
the good doctor this is the only fight I
actually care about to be totally real
here I'm gonna watch the [__] out of
this
[Music]
here we go
yeah there's a significant height
difference there yeah
and the age difference you know
[Music]
well he did encourage us um yeah but
they have a similar physique
[Music]
actually Wings might even be a little
bigger
[Music]
but the certainly an interesting matchup
[Applause]
bro come on you both in the same
physical as shape
[Music]
dude
what can his keemstar game running in
the [__] back
like the like the Grim Reaper dude
[Laughter]
look at that demonic smile
oh this dude's about to claim a few
Souls
[Laughter]
uh yeah but but I do wish that I I hope
you know I wish everybody uh a good
fight and nobody gets injured or
anything like that yeah please I hope
they will be okay they do stay safe out
there I mean the chance sitting gets
really injured because
if someone Falls it'll be bad that's for
sure especially Boogie because he's a
bit older
right but
like just I I just being real I don't
know do they have like a center of
gravity advantage or balance issues I
don't know
[Music]
I don't know either
I'm just trying to analyze this from
like a professional boxing
what what looks professional to you
so wait is this tomorrow okay I'm kind
of hyped so I'm not even gonna lie
and Boogie if you do die tomorrow uh it
was all there's never any bad blood it
was all good bro
[Music]
it's all good brother
I remember the good times man
we had some good shows together didn't
we
should I start as eulogy tonight or stop
joking about it oh okay
there's a little less than zero chance
that he will die tomorrow and then
you're gonna feel really [__] mad
hold on hold on hold on if he dies
tomorrow I didn't do [__] let's just
stop discussing that possibility it's
not manifest okay it's not manifest hold
on hold on the fact that there's a
non-zero chance of him dying tomorrow is
is this it's on them yeah they did this
they created the situation I got it but
you're not it's bad juju you're putting
out into the universe right now
bad juju
you don't want no bad juju right it's
not it's out of my hands man
I prefer really not to you know it's
honestly kind of sad because he's doing
it for money and he has like a high
likelihood to injure himself yeah but
he's doing it for money that's like
horrible yeah no it's it's these guys
are the ones exploiting them I'm just
I'm just saying it I see it oh yeah for
sure I think it's funny I mean he he
seems to have the attitude that this has
motivated him to you know lose some
weight and get off his ass and
everything and
um that's all true but like this
probably just isn't the best way to go
about it because I mean you're going on
50 bro and you're really overweight
like
boxing is dangerous enough as it is for
healthy people you know yeah so wait
wait wait wait I am curious how much
he's getting paid you know what I mean
is are we talking three thousand dollars
are we talking like fifty thousand
um I'm thinking it's three yeah
definitely not 50. I mean his medical
bills are going to far surpass that
I do feel for him though I mean it's
scary for anyone but like the thought of
thinking that I had to do it for money
is uh
[__]
it's like a bum fight almost
yeah
you know and we've frown upon bum fights
[Laughter]
this is okay
you know I almost spit my Boba out
you know what bomb fights is Sheila no
this guy used to go on the street and
he'd collect all these homeless people
and he'd pay him to fight
um put it on VHS wow it was called bum
fights and this dude made a whole bunch
of money he must have gone to jail for
that though right I think we talked
about it at one point and
and I think we did find that out I I
have or maybe I'm confusing that with
the girls gone wild guy
that dude
bum fights Wikipedia let's let's see
let's see what's going on with bump
fights
that's now what a [__] up thing this
was
um keemstar's that guy
[__]
Kim said it's like squid games yeah so
different
um it doesn't it looks like he didn't go
to jail but he did get sued which they
ended up settling and that was kind of
the end of it so I probably realized it
was a bad idea
appearance on Dr Phil
the bump oh I remember he actually I
called out Dr Phil right he had an
iconic um actually quite a poignant
to be totally honest he dressed up as Dr
Phil and was like you're gonna sit here
and lecture me [__] you do the same
thing interesting he's not wrong here
let me pull that up um he caught his
hair and [__] bum fight stuff for Phil
I mean dude I've been hearing a lot of
Dr Phil over the last like year or so
because Ali will put it on while she's
working sometimes oh yeah um because she
Ali just loves schlocky reality TV stuff
and um
and like I didn't really ever know about
Dr Phil but oh he's a giant [__] yeah
he [__] sucks oh yeah [__] really
do not like him oh yeah
give me 200.
[Music]
I just I'll just give you guys a little
bit of a taste here oh showing his show
might be I'm just gonna show a little
bit here oh there he is okay so he comes
out dressed just like [__] Dr Phil Dr
Phil has this whole intro about what a
piece of shitty is
and then
is it able to claim these pixels I mean
what the [__]
yeah
if you if you think I exploit people
every time you bring a guest on this
show you exploit them and spread
whatever the problems they have to the
whole world you think that's helping
them yeah keep telling yourself that
he's not wrong Dr Phil don't hide from
the door interesting he's he's not he's
not ready to face that
who do you think you
think you want come on come on huh I'm
not finished talking to you yeah you are
oh they removed him picked him off oh he
got too real for them
oh that's good
I've made multi-millions off the bomb
fights videos yeah this guy's a [__]
psychotic freak
stop the tape
I don't want to talk to you
he bitched out because he knew he was
right he was he was on thin ice on this
one why not that's despicable
I don't want to talk to you
invite him on dummy so dumb you didn't
know who he was you're probably showing
too much though we're gonna get claimed
by Dr Phil how are they gonna claim two
pixels move in no just yeah don't watch
it oh shame
anyway well that's about it I'm actually
really looking forward to that fight
tomorrow and um
do you know what the mourner's kiddish
is
do I know what what now what did you
just say what's it called in Hebrew
there's a prayer you say
oh I see called the mourner's uh kiddish
kadish oh you know that one
kadish
yeah that's not the yamle uh
exit here I'll read it in the English
this is just a prayer
do you think that I hate the Jews is
this a button moment well the button's
off so uh exalt exalted and Hallowed be
God's Great name in the world which God
created according to his plan may God's
Majesty be revealed in the days of our
lifetime and the life of all Israel
speedily imminently to which we say Amen
blessed be God's name to all eternity
blessed praised honored exalted
extolled glorified adored and lauded be
the name of the Holy blessed one be on
all Earthly words and songs of blessings
praise and comfort to which we say amen
amen amen May there be abundant peace
from heaven and life
for us and all of Israel to which we say
Amen May the one who creates uh Harmony
and on high bring peace to us all in
Israel to which we say amen and that is
a beautiful prayer that we say
every Friday to uh the recently deceased
we do that to put their soul at ease
foreign
you go to the Shabbat and then they go
does anybody want to put out a name for
to bless them and people would raise up
to be like my Uncle Dave
my father Jeffrey so
just in case
I don't know why y'all I didn't do
anything maybe you should go to
synagogue tonight and do that for real
to make up for uh the juju that you're
putting out into the world right now I'm
not putting [__] out
oh I'm off the screen
this is all not in this episode whatever
happens is all on keemstar and The
Misfits
you know
that ain't me
that's that ain't me
I'm just in the Coliseum you know what I
mean I ain't got nothing to do with this
I didn't put the I didn't put the hungry
lions in there with the [__] x-cons
like I'm just there in the Coliseum you
know I mean that's on the emperor I
didn't do [__] I'm just here to watch
[Laughter]
all right guys have a great weekend
um and yeah it's all love uh Boogie uh
I'm sorry about the conflicts that we
had it's not fair that uh we fell out
like that after all that are you hoping
he wins the fight
um I yeah I'm rooting for him yeah I
just hope they both
exit the fight without permanent damage
to their bodies nothing yeah I hope they
both have fun
I hope they both have a great time me
too yeah
yes yes that's what I hope as well I
hope they both slay yeah they will so
that's what slay me careful
careful you uh whoa Ila what the hell
then what I said
I wish they died oh my Lord
they're gonna Yasin that ring
um have a great weekend everybody thanks
for being here another great week of
shows had so much fun thank you to
everybody
oh Sunday right there's the uh for
members
basically a special exclusive 40 minute
yeah with all of it it's real it look
let's not over hype it it's just it's
just us all hanging out watching the
video and kind of reminiscing the
memories of it and stuff it's it's I
thought it was a little for fun it is
nice it is nice talk about the
allegations okay very cool all right so
we'll see you guys next week love y'all
God bless God bless uh and yada yada
yada and uh
see ya
thanks
[Music]